hey this is Andrew Brown from exam pro
and welcome to another cloud
certification and this time it's Oracle
Foundation's associate certification it
is the entry level certification for the
Oracle cloud infrastructure platform and
I'm going to show you in less than a
week how to pass this certification and
if you are new to cloud it's a really
great one to do and I have some really
great fall alarms for you that's going
to show you how to set up your account
how to launch an instance in database
and just generally understand the
reasons why you'd want to use cloud so
you know I hope you enjoy this course
please do the fall Long's it's going to
really help you pass and I'd love to
hear your feedback and if you do pass
definitely share that with me because I
love to hear that you're passing these
courses and I'll see you soon
[Music]
so I want to do a quick comparison
between the OCI foundations and the aid
of a certified cloud practitioner
certification both these certifications
are foundational so they are the first
certification you would take if you're
starting out on cloud but let's get into
it and the first thing is that the OCI
foundation certification is only valid
for 1.5 years and that is a very short
period of time the eighth of a
certifications are generally two years
but as of recent the CCP is now valid
for three years and so why Oracle did
this I do not know but I I guess that
the reason they might have done this is
that because their platform is so new
they're anticipating that their platform
is going to rapidly change in the next
couple of years and they don't want to
have a bunch of certification holders
who claim to know how to use their
platform when the platform is so
different so maybe the next time in the
next two years we'll see they'll have
new versions of their certifications and
they'll be valid for a longer period of
time but right now it's a very short
period of time I do not like that one
thing I want to point out is that the
OCI foundation certification is five
dollars cheaper than the CCP that is a
very minut difference but it might
matter to you if you're on a budget if
you are going for multiple
certifications beyond the foundational
cert one thing I really like that eight
of us does is that give you half off the
next
certification so if you sat the CCP
which is $100 and you go for an
associate which is generally $150 it's
now just $75 so you're spending $175 for
two certifications Oracle does not have
such deal right now if if you're
listening Oracle I strongly recommend
that you adopt this because it's very
very cool but right now they do not have
it so
you're gonna get a better deal on the
side with AWS if you've ever taken the
AZ 900 or the 80 of the CCP and you're
wondering whether you should go take the
Oracle Foundation's I'm gonna tell you
that the knowledge transfer is extremely
good if you were to pull up all three of
these certifications on the screen right
now like the exam guides you notice that
they're their outlines are extremely
similar so the only difference is that
the names of the services are different
and there's some differences in billing
so if you already have that CCP and you
want to add another certification to
your roster certifications and you have
the money I do strongly go recommend and
get the Oracle Foundation's one thing I
don't like about their exam is that it
doesn't have weighted domains and I'll
we'll talk about this in an upcoming
slide but the problem with that is that
if they're not weighted that means that
the exam isn't going to be as balanced
as it could be and so it'll be harder
not because it's technically difficult
but because the the balancing is off so
hopefully they will solve this in the
future this is a pro or a con depending
on the way you look at it but they are a
very young cloud provider so they don't
have as much stuff as AWS but that's
also advantage if you are new to cloud
so if you find AWS extremely
overwhelming and you want to have a work
on a simpler platform you can dig into
Oracle and grow with the platform as
they add more additional services and
the last thing or not the last thing but
I want to point out that their
documentation is very fragmented this
was very hard for me to put this course
together because there was conflicting
information or just I had to fill in the
blanks for you here and I think I did
take the best guests here but that is
one thing that I wish they would improve
upon and the last thing and this is the
most important thing is that there is a
lack of Oracle certification holders
and Oracle is a very old company they've
around since the 70s and there's a lot
of companies using Oracle so if you do
get working certifications I definitely
believe there are jobs out there we're
having these certs are going to matter I
do consider it a smaller market than the
eight above certifications but if you
are looking to stand out then this is a
great certification to get so there you
go so let's take a look here at the exam
guide and this is the outline of what's
actually going to be required of us to
pass the exam and then after we go
through the highlights here we'll
actually open up the actual exam guide
I'll show you where you can find that
information so the first thing is the
domains and so the domains are clogged
concepts Ossa infrastructure asset core
services security billing and pricing
but one thing you're going to notice is
that there are there is no domain
weighting on this exam so these domains
we don't know if the exam is comprised
of 40% of the questions of security 10%
if these are all evenly distributed we
just don't have that information and so
that is one of the downsides of Oracle
certifications I think maybe in the
future they might tell us but at this
time I could not figure out how the how
the questions are distributed but that's
just what it is to pass this exam you're
gonna have to get a 68% I don't know if
we're a khole I do know things about
Oracle but I don't know if they they do
it at based on like a point system so on
either bus it's like a thousand out of
whatever so you know you'd have to get
680 points to score out of a thousand
but anyway we know the passing grade is
68% there are 60 questions on the exam
and so you can afford to get 19
questions wrong and all the questions
are multiple-choice there's no no
questions where you have to multi-select
any boxes so that's a little bit nice
all right well it turns out I was
actually wrong it does have multiple
choice and multiple answers I just
wanted to quickly correct that there and
we'll go back to the video so yeah
you're gonna get a combination of both
and you could see multiple answers where
they might be asking you between two and
three choices
to choose from and then multiple choice
would be just one out of the four but
there you go you have a hundred five
minutes to take this exam so that means
you're gonna roughly have two minutes
per questions it's gonna be less than
two minutes but you're gonna have a lot
of time to pass this exam and I strongly
recommend I strongly recommend that you
go back and review all your questions
and make sure that you made the correct
choices because sometimes when you're
studying you're just in a hurry to get
to the end so you don't run out on the
clock and you should really go and take
a second look at your questions and the
last thing is that this exam is only
valid for 18 months so once you get the
certification you do have to get
recertified in 1.5 years and I did say
earlier that I I found that a strong
disadvantage for Oracle certifications
and maybe that will change in the future
but that's just how it is right now but
there you go and we'll go jump into the
actual duck of the actual PDFs now so
here I have the exam guide opened in
front of us here so we can get a bit
better details of what the domains are
one thing I couldn't usually find was
how long the certification was valid for
the way I found it was there was another
marketing page and from this page there
was this link and in this link it told
us it was valid for 18 months and that's
how I found out you have to get your
certified in 1.5 years why it's not in
this documentation I have no idea or I
might have just not noticed it but I
just wanted to point that out if you're
trying to validate what I'm saying about
the how long the certification is valid
for so let's hop hop over to the
certification details here and just give
it a quick zoom in here
and you're going to notice that the exam
number or for this exam is one seven
zero one zero a 5 - 20 I do not know why
they named it that because it's very
complicated maybe they have a lot of
other exams were not aware of but that
is the name of your exam number it's
very important to know your exam number
because if there are future exams you
need to know which one you are taking
because the content might be different
here they say the target audience is
designed for technical and non-technical
professionals involved in selling and
purchasing OCI infrastructure which I
I agree with to take this exam you can
take it via Pearson VUE so that is the
partnered data set or test center
network so there's a few different tests
test center networks and Pearson VUE is
very well known one for their
approximate exams proctored mean that
you can take the exams online so you can
take this in a test center and that is
the preferred way that's the way I
suggest you to take your exams or you
can take it online where they connect
via webcam and they make sure that you
you aren't cheating and then you just
take it from the comfort of your own
home we can see that's 105 minutes we
have ninety-five dollars for the exam
cost and it looks like it says 25%
discount on the list price if you are
and OPN so part of the Oracle partner
network you are likely not part of the
Oracle partner network if it's anything
like the Amazon partner network you have
to do a lot of work to join that but if
you are working for a company and they
have this and you can save a bit of
money and the passing score here is 68%
again it doesn't tell us the points it
doesn't say 680 points it doesn't tell
us the breakdown of the the scoring but
we'll take a look here and maybe I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure it does not
then we have some stuff about
certification benefits
nothing super exciting here but this is
what the badge looks like so once you
pass the exam you can download this
digital badge and you're going to want
to you could just put this on your
website but the huge advantage is you
wanted to have that certificate and put
in your LinkedIn so everyone can see it
that's the the main goal of getting
certifications is putting them on your
LinkedIn and so we'll just scroll down a
little bit and now we'll get to the
actual exam topics or I like to call
them domains because most other
providers call them domains so the first
one is cloud concepts so ant understand
terms like scalable elastic agility
fault tolerance capex op X understand
the difference between IAS SPSS and SAS
understand public private hybrid models
reduce TCO with migrations on pram Clow
without we architected then you have the
getting started with Oracle
infrastructure so describe the key
features components of OC ISO multi ad
one
dat fault domains console api's CL eyes
and SDKs I don't think we covered these
two things but there's not much to talk
about
so I don't know why they have it there
because I did not see it on the exam
Oracle cloud infrastructure services so
understand the core services I am
compute network storage databases
understand cloud native services oke o
CR o FF n streaming API gateway so
that's kind of interesting then you have
security compliance so OCI security
services so vc n SL at ste wife etc etc
pricing support and operations so OC a
pricing model understand o CI
subscription models pricing calculator
free tier the OCI SLA OC operations o CI
concepts like budgets quota limits and
support so that is the breakdown of
information that we need to learn and
that we're going to cover that all in
the exam what's surprising is that they
don't have any white paper so with AWS
they usually have technical white papers
they want you to read Oracle DAC Chua li
does have white papers but it doesn't
appear to be part of their exam just yet
so maybe it'll do that in the future
there's some information about like exam
score if we pop over here doesn't really
tell us much about how the scoring works
it's just saying that you'll get the
score with Pearson VUE after the fact
and there's just some other information
so hopefully that helps you better
understand the breakdown of the exam and
now we can jump into the actual content
itself and start learning Oracle
so with on Prem or on premise you own
the servers you hire the IT people you
pay the rent or real estate and you take
all the risk but with using the cloud
someone else owns the servers someone
else hires the IT people someone else
pays pays or rents the real estate and
all you're left to do is with the
responsibility or cloud services and
code and everything else is taken care
by the cloud provider so it sounds
pretty good to start with so to really
understand cloud computing let's look at
the evolution of servers to see how we
got to cloud so if we go back to the 90s
it
you wanted a server you'd have to get a
dedicated server and what that means is
you'd have to go out by a physical
machine or all the components for it
assemble that machine hire the IT staff
install the operating system and it was
really designed only to run a single web
app or website and so this was very
expensive it was very high maintenance
so if you wanted to run a web app you
had to have a lot of money so it wasn't
accessible to everybody and then as time
progressed we figured out how to
virtualized servers that means we were
able to place a virtual machine within a
machine so you'd still buy a physical
server but we had this other layer where
we could actually run for websites or
web apps on a single machine as opposed
to buying four machines so the machine
was better utilized and so that was a
great advantage in server technology
then came along shared hosting so maybe
the early 2000s the idea is that you had
this one physical machine but instead of
you having to buy that machine yourself
which was really expensive you could
share the cost with hundreds of other
businesses and the way your isolated
from other businesses is that you would
wouldn't be necessarily in your own
virtual machine but you have your own
account on that machine and so you're
really relying on other tenants so
clients under utilizing the resources
the only disadvantage of shared hosting
is that if you have a particular client
who over uses the machine everybody
suffers because that person is overusing
the the the resources but generally most
of the time it's very cheap but there
are some serious limitations and then
Along Came cloud and so the cloud did
was instead of using a single machine
you're able to use multiple physical
machines that act as one system so the
system abstracted the system's has
affected away and we just called in
cloud services and so the advantage here
is that you get that virtual isolation
which you have with virtual machines but
you also get to save a lot of money
because you're sharing the cost with a
lot of other people and and you've got
all these other advantages so with cloud
hosting it's flexible scalable secure
cost-effective and high highly
configurable if
isn't clear right now it will be later
later on because I'm definitely going to
really make the difference is very clear
here and all these models are still used
so people still use dedicated servers
virtual private servers shared hosting
and cloud hosting it's just a based on
your use case but there's a lot we can
do with cloud so let's take a quick look
at what Oracle is you may have seen
their logo before if you've worked in
enterprise or you've been working in
tech for a very long time because they
are a very well-known company they are
an American multinational computer
technology corporation headquartered in
Redwood Shores California they are the
second largest software company by
revenue and market capitalization that
is a quote from Wikipedia so I believe
that it may be true and they have been
around since the late 1970s and that
explains why they are in Redwood Shores
California because a lot of tech
companies established themselves there I
think Microsoft did as well and they're
best known for their databases so it's
always a surprise and people say oh they
are a cloud provider I thought they only
do databases they do other things and
one database you might know is the MySQL
database so Oracle has their own
database called Oracle but they also
have MySQL I don't believe they
originally made it I think they bought
it and it's an open source database but
those are two very popular databases so
then the question is is what is Oracle
cloud infrastructure and that is what
Oracle calls their cloud service
provider so with AWS that is so we have
Amazon and so Amazon's is called Amazon
Web service for Google is called Google
cloud provider and so Oracle calls
theirs Oracle cloud infrastructure so
that's just what it is and so we can
generally refer to it as Oracle cloud
infrastructure so OCI or Oracle cloud so
when I say either of these or all three
of these these are all the same thing
just so you don't get confused and that
is what we're focused on for the
certification learning the Oracle cloud
infrastructure
[Music]
let's talk about the advantages of cloud
computing and the first thing is
on-demand so you only pay for the
resources that you consume there's no
upfront cost with cloud computing you
generally pay by the hour or by the
minute or second depending on the
service so you don't have to buy a
server right or or necessarily commit to
like a like a one-year three-year or
five-year contract so there's a lot more
flexibility there if you want to start
doing business anywhere in the world you
can because with cloud computing you can
launch your workloads anywhere if you
want to launch servers in Tokyo
Frankfurt or Canada you can just do that
there is no extra work in order to start
doing that the cost is a lot cheaper
because you're sharing the cost with
thousands of other customers all those
computers have been treated like a
single computer so the idea is that you
are really saving a lot of money because
there's so many people on the platform
but you still secure because you're all
virtually isolated from each other you
no longer have to do a lot of upfront
work to launch a server or set up
infrastructure so if this was on Prem
you would have to decide ok we're gonna
have this kind of networking and these
kind of servers and we're gonna to hire
these kind of people and so you have to
really plan for your project in the old
way but with cloud you can just start
launching resources experiments and as
you experiment you have detailed
monitoring on a lot of those services
and so that's gonna make it a lot easier
for you to figure out exactly what you
need and you don't really have to guess
if you are launching a physical server
like if you're doing on Prem you might
and you're expecting you're gonna have a
lot of growth you might end up having to
buy a bunch of servers that are not
being utilized because you haven't met
that capacity yet but with the cloud
it's elastic so you can add or remove
servers when need be so you're only
paying for the actual capacity that you
need so that's really nice and the last
thing is that it's really really fast to
market so with a few clicks you're going
to be able to set up a bunch of
infrastructure where if you were doing
this on your own it could take weeks or
months if you had to do it in your own
premise or data center so hopefully that
points out what are the advantages of so
let's take a look at the types of cloud
computing and starting at the top of our
pyramid and I promise you this is not a
pyramid scheme it is just a great way of
doing this visualization at the top we
have a software-as-a-service
also known as SAS this is a product that
is run and managed by a service provider
you do not worry about how the service
is maintained it just works and remains
available examples of sasses would be
Salesforce Gmail and office 365 and this
is for customers so you've probably used
a SAS product and you just don't know it
is the most common type of cloud
computing so you've been using cloud all
along then the next level down is
platform as a service which is paas or
maybe people would say pass but I've
never heard anyone say it like that
and this focuses on the deployment and
management of your apps so you don't
worry about provisioning configuring or
understanding to Hardware OS to launch
your app look your web applications so
this for eight of us is could be elastic
Beanstalk there's also Heroku which is a
very popular provider among junior
developers and then you have Google
Google App Engine and this is really
suited for developers it just makes
development a lot easy without you
having to worry about setting up your
servers and then at the bottom we have
infrastructure as a service and so this
is the basic building blocks for cloud
IT provides access to Network features
computers data storage space you do not
worry about the IT staff the datacenters
or hardware and this is really what we
are interested in so examples could be
Microsoft Azure AWS and Oracle cloud and
this is really intended for admins or
being able to do anything and everything
that you want so when we look at Oracle
cloud it is an IAS or ice I don't know
how to say that but you it also has
platform as a service and software as a
service so when you look at that pyramid
you have to understand that
infrastructure to service the bottom
encompasses everything so you know
hopefully that makes sense but yeah
that's the types of cloud computing
[Music]
so let's talk about cloud deployment
models here very quickly so the first is
cloud native and this is where
everything is built on the cloud so
here's an example of an architectural
diagram what it does is it takes an
image you upload it to the cloud and
then what it does is it turns it into a
thumbnail and it gives it back to you
but the point I want to get across here
is that when we're talking about using
the cloud as a deployment model that
means that we're 100% using the cloud
then you have hybrid architectures also
just known as hybrid that's where you
use on-prem and the cloud again on-prem
would mean like your own local data
center and then cloud would be the cloud
provider and so what you could have here
is you could have on the left-hand side
this is the cloud network and then you
have the on-premise network and they're
being joined together to do work
together so just because you utilizing
cloud doesn't mean you have to get rid
of your your your local data center or
your on-premise data center you can use
both and it's very common with large
enterprises because there are definitely
reasons to keep on Prem around for
security regulations and or just because
you've had a data center for so long
it's just too hard to move everything
over to cloud then you have a cross
cloud and this is we're using multiple
cloud providers some people might call
this multi cloud or a hybrid cloud and
so this is an example where we have AWS
and left GCP on the right and we have
azure connecting them together for the
actual exam most cloud providers do not
like mentioning cross cloud because they
really want you to focus on their cloud
platform some are more friendly than
others for Oracle they they're very
collaborative with Azure or Microsoft so
you'll see a lot of stuff cross cloud
with those two providers Oracle and
Microsoft and then Microsoft tries to
connect to everything but yeah those are
the three deployment models but for the
exam it's probably gonna be like cloud
hybrid and on Prem I just list that last
one there for your own benefit
[Music]
so let's talk about cloud architectural
terminologies which is very important
about the cloud so the first term I want
you to know is called availability and
this is the ability for a service and
when I say service
I mean web application to remain
available and if we had an application
that was very very available we would
call that high availability h.a and that
is a term you definitely need to know I
don't worry we're just going through a
quick list here and then we're gonna
actually look at them all in more
granular detail but I'm just going to
quickly go through all these terms this
next one is scalability so this is the
ability to grow rapidly or grow where
you're unimpeded
so that is scalability then you have
elasti elasticity this is the ability to
shrink or grow to meet the current
demand then you have fault tolerance
this is the ability to prevent a failure
then you have disaster recovery this is
the ability to recover from a failure
and we usually call this being highly
durable so it's bringing it to dr I'm
sure these other ones have abbreviations
but generally the only two that people
know is H a and TR so this is the two
ones I want to emphasize so let's take a
look first at high availability and this
is your ability for your service to
remain available by ensuring there is no
single point of failure and/or ensure a
certain level of performance now I put
no single point of failure because some
of these terminologies kind of overlap
in terms of responsibilities and so
single point of failure is really for
responsible for another one but you know
I do highlight it here just to make the
example but easier so an example of
having high abilities imagine you have a
server and if you only had a single
server and for whatever reason if the
data center became unavailable like
let's say there was a outage or a
network outage or or some sort or
natural disaster then your website would
not be accessible anymore so in order to
make it highly available what we need to
do is we need to run our server in more
than one data center and so that's what
you're seeing in that graph where you
see 81 82
eighty-three we have three servers
running in three data centers and then
we are sending all the traffic to all of
them and actually running your your your
your your service in more than one data
center and in fact three and three
different data centers is a very very
common practice is generally a minimum
requirement for a lot of enterprise
companies because if one data center was
to go out then you need to have another
redundant data center that that has your
service running but if two went out and
that's very unlikely but it's totally
possible that's why you need a third one
so three is the magic number and you
need to definitely remember that but
what is the mechanism that allows us to
distribute traffic to all these three
different data centers where we have
servers in each one and that's called a
load balancer and so every cloud
provider has a load balancer and I
believe Oracle's is called the Oracle
load balancer and so a load balancer
allows you to evenly distribute traffic
to multiple servers in one or more
multiple data centers if a data center
or a server becomes unavailable and so
we could say that that means that it's
unhealthy the load bouncer would route
traffic to only healthy data centers and
servers so again the thing here this red
thing that's the load balancer that's
the internet from the internet we have
traffic coming in and then it's going to
evenly distribute to all those servers
so that is high availability so the next
cloud architecture terminology we want
to talk about is high scalability so
this is your ability to increase your
capacity based on the increasing demand
of traffic memory and computing power so
imagine you have a server and the server
is not powerful enough to run your
service so what would you do the first
thing most people do is they buy a
bigger server and this is called
vertical scaling or scaling up because
you are you're using the same machine
and you are making it bigger so that is
what vertical scaling is another way to
scale is called horizontal scaling and
this is where you scale out so you're
adding more servers of the same size so
that's vertical scaling and horizontal
scaling you need to know scaling up and
scaling out but that is the general
concept of high scalability so now let's
take a look at high elasticity so this
is your ability to automatically
increase or decrease your capacity based
on the current demand of traffic memory
and computing power sounds a lot like
the last one but there's one key
difference and that is that you can add
remove servers how to remove based on
the current demand of traffic and so the
only way we're going to be able to do
this is with horizontal scaling but when
we are adding more servers we call that
scaling out and we're removing servers
because the traffic is it has reduced in
size that is called scaling in and so
you generally won't hear the term
vertical scaling with high elasticity
because generally it's very hard for
traditional architectures to to to scale
elastically it's very hard to resize a
single server to make it larger or
smaller it's a lot easier to add extra
servers of the same size so you just
generally will only see it associated
with horizontal scaling now the question
is this how would you automatically
scale in or out and generally they're
all claw providers to have the service
for that the one that is for Oracle is
called auto scaling configuration so in
OCI you can configure scaling rules for
your instances with the Oracle auto
scaling configuration so you could say
when my server is is being the CPUs
being 75% utilize add another server and
when it goes down then remove another
server and so high elasticity is a
really great way to save money but also
to make sure that your web application
remains available because it can meet
the current demand of traffic
[Music]
so let's talk about being fault-tolerant
so this is your ability for your service
to ensure there is no single point of
failure preventing the chance of failure
you'll notice I had mentioned this in
high availability the no single point of
failure thing it really means fault
tolerant but you'll see in the example
it kind of seems very similar to our
other example there where we have
redundant systems to make sure that we
don't have a problem so here's an
example we have a database and so we
have a master database and something's
happened to our database and so we want
to make sure that in the case of failure
we can fail over to a redundant system
so we call this a slave and it's on
standby because it's not in active use
but it will be once we move it over in a
really good way to conceptualize this is
if if you think of like a play like for
theater you have the lead actor or
actress and they always have an
understudy a person that will take the
the the main actor actresses place if
they get sick and they will know
everything they'll be up-to-date on
everything and so that is what we have
here where we have that says it's in
sync because that standby slave has the
exact same information as the master
it's just not in use and so the and so
when there is a failure we call it a
failover that that's when you plan to
shift the traffic to the redundant
system in the case the primary system
fails so that is fault tolerance so
let's talk about high durability and
this is the last one on our list so this
is your ability to recover from a
disaster and to prevent the loss of data
so solutions that recover from a
disaster is known as disaster recovery
dr you're gonna want to remember that
abbreviation it's used a lot in the
cloud and so imagine you have a database
if you had a single database and
something happened to it you would be
out of business so you want to have
backups you might also want to run your
database and multiple data centers
across multiple regions and that's what
we're doing here and then we want to
have backups so that is generally like a
very simplified way of thinking about
disaster recovery but the questions you
should be asking is do you have backups
fast can you restore that back up does
your backup still work just because you
have a backup doesn't mean it works and
how can you ensure your current live
data is not corrupt so just because you
have a backup
maybe there's actually a bug in the
real-time database so maybe an analogy
would be imagine that you have defective
cells in your body your body wants to
repair those cells so you don't get
cancer so it's always replacing old dead
cells and and this thing can actually
also happen with databases where you
have bad data and you don't want that
bad data to spread so you can have self
cell a self-healing database so
hopefully that makes clear what high
durability is so let's talk about the
total cost of ownership TCO but you
might also know this as capex and OPEX
as a comparison of what the total cost
of ownership is and to understand this
this concept I have this nice
visualization where I have two icebergs
and where you have the ice cap and then
what's underneath some people don't
think this looks like icebergs they
think they look like teeth or something
strange so what I've done is I've added
some penguins and a whale so that you
know that they are icebergs and this is
the best I can draw so you know don't
give me too hard of a time
but let's look at the comparison here so
on the left-hand side there is capex and
this would generally be your on-prem and
you'd be purchasing software license
fees and then you have OPEX on the
right-hand side so this would be your
cloud provider so in our case this is
OCI
and what you are paying for is
subscription fees so the idea here is
that the total cost of ownership is is
that the idea is that if you want to own
everything that you have to pay for
everything and the idea is that by a
letting go of the ownership of things
and you're going to have a lot of
reduced costs and also reduce
responsibilities and that's gonna be
better for you in the long run but let's
look at on-prem so if you're on pram you
have to worry about implementation
configuration training and then the
large cost there is the physical
security of your building the hardware
that you need to buy and install and
maintain you the IT personnel so all the
people to manage you
or on-prem data center but when you move
to the cloud you don't have to do any of
that all you have to worry about is
implementation configuration and
training all that other stuff that
infrastructure to run your servers and
everything is abstracted away and so
what you could see is about 75% savings
so that's the eight of us example I'm
sure it's the same for Oracle but the
idea is that previously you're paying a
lot of money and now you're paying very
little money you can just focus on
building your software but what we
really need to do for the Oracle
certification is really understand capex
and OPEX because that's what they like
to talk about so we're just going to
cover this again and make sure you
understand those two terms very clearly
[Music]
let's talk about capex versus OPEX and
so capex stands for capital expenditure
and opera and OPEC stands for
operational expenditures so for capital
expenditure this is your on-prem costs
like if you own everything so you own or
rent the building you've owned the
vehicles so maybe like company vehicles
you own the hardware you own any type of
equipment to do the job and maybe you
even own the lands or you rent the land
so there is capital expenses there a lot
of people still like to do on prim or
data center because they care about
capital expenses because they can get
tax breaks and other things like that I
don't think that's a great practice
because you know it's better to not
worry about these things
but some people that is a motivator in
the enterprise world it's like oh well
if we purchased it as a capital expense
then we get to get a discount on it for
operational expenditures that would be
like the products you purchase the
business itself or any systems so
operational expenditures but the key
takeaway I want you to have there is
capital expenditures stands for capital
that's where you buy things out rate and
OPEX is operational expenditures and
that's OPEX and this concept is the same
thing as the TCO where we're just
looking at the difference between
between who has ownership of what okay
[Music]
so I know we already covered the
evolution of servers but I really wanted
to make sure you understand the
evolution of computing visually and the
trade-offs as to why because it's gonna
really help you understand the
difference between a bare-metal machine
VMs containers and functions so what we
have here is a graphical representation
of a bare-metal or you might call it a
dedicated machine so the idea here is
that we have a physical server that is
wholly utilized by a single customer you
don't have you have to guess your
capacity and you'll probably overpay for
an underutilized server so if you have
an application or multiple applications
you're always you can end up with a
wasted space because you're always gonna
have to buy a larger server because
you're anticipating you're gonna have to
fill it but that space is going to be
costing you money because it's not being
utilized upgrade beyond your capacity
will be slow and expensive because you'd
have to buy an additional server or
you'd have to replace the server you're
limited by the operating system so you
have one operating system installed it's
going to be hard to patch an update
especially if you have multiple
applications and if you do have multiple
applications running on a single server
because you're trying to save money you
might have conflicts and reason we're
sharing so one might use more memory
than the others because they're not
virtually isolated or one could cause a
vulnerability than the other one but the
advantages of having a dedicated or
bare-metal machine is that you have a
guarantee of security privacy and full
utility of the underlying resources but
with the caveat that you're actually
able to configure it so that it is
secure private and etc and so notice
that I have an a strict over the word
dedicated so dedicated could just mean
that you wholly utilize the single
customer but the thing with bare metal
is that there is no hypervisor layer so
you could have a dedicated virtual
machine or a dedicated bare metal
machine but you've never actually ever
have a bare metal sheen that is not
dedicated I don't think there is a
shared version of it so just note that
there is no hypervisor at this layer
it's like the original server where you
have no no extra software layer for
abstraction
[Music]
so now we're going to take a look at
vm's they're also known as virtual
machines so you can run multiple virtual
machines on one machine so look at our
graphic there and you'll notice that
it's not just one app it's multiple
applications and so the way we're able
to launch virtual machines is with the
software layer layer called hypervisor
that's all you need to remember that
hypervisor is the one that makes virtual
machines work and it's a physical server
shared by multiple customers if it
wasn't you're the only one using it it
would be called a dedicated machine so
you can definitely have dedicated
virtual machines just depends on how you
want to use that word dedicated you only
pay for a fraction of the server because
you're sharing that cost of everyone
else you're still overpaying for
underutilized virtual machines so the
whole server you're not paying for the
entire server anymore you're paying for
the slice of server that you've chosen
to use you are limited by the guest
operating system so the machine has an
operating system and in the virtual
machine you have the guest operating
system but if you want to run multiple
apps they're all limited by that that
same one but multiple apps on a single
virtual machine can result in conflicts
and resource sharing so we still have
the problem as we did before where one
app could use more memory than the other
and there's no way of setting limits on
each individual app so that is virtual
machines and we'll move on to containers
[Music]
so now with containers what we have done
is we are running a virtual machine
that's running multiple containers and
so container is just another isolation
of your application but it also bundles
in with it like OS layer and package
stuff so we're not bound by the actual
operating system so the the software
layer that controls the ability to run
multiple containers if you're using
docker is called a docker daemon it's
like hypervisor but that's for
containers and your server can have
hypervisor and docker Damons at the same
time but the best part about this is
that now we can maximize the utility of
our server so instead of it being wasted
space it we now have available capacity
and it's a lot more cost-effective
because it's very easy for us to launch
isolate isolate applications and we
don't have to worry about them affecting
each other and we don't have to worry
about messing with the configuration
with us because it's all isolated so
your containers share the same
underlying OS but the containers are
more efficient than multiple VMs and
multiple apps can run side-by-side
without being limited to the same OS
requirements and will not cause
conflicts during resource sharing so you
look at this and you say how can we get
any better than this and that's what
functions will be next but you know
hopefully the takeaway here is that we
have less wasted space with containers
or I should say now the space is more
flexible or available for us to utilize
[Music]
so now we'll take a look here at
functions and functions breaks down our
computing even further so what we do
have is we have a managed VM and we also
have managed containers so we're not
responsible for the containers or the
VMS the cloud provider has ones for us
and this is known as service compute
because you don't have to worry about
like setting up the containers or
setting up the VMS or anything all you
need to do is upload your code and
choose the amount of memory and duration
that you need and you're only
responsible for the code and data and
nothing else so it's extremely cost
effective and you only pay for the time
the code runs
VMs only run when there is code to be
executed the only downside to
functions or service compute is that
they generally have a cold start so the
these the VM that runs the action or the
containers that need to need to be
launched and so there's that time it
takes for it to launch and that's the
only that's the only downside but there
are ways around it but the point is is
that with with serverless or or or
service compute it you can see that
there's a lot less responsibilities that
you have to manage but there is lack of
flexibility because you you're
constrained with whatever those manage
containers are have but anyway that's
function hey this is Andrew Brown from
exam pro and we are starting on a new
section here called the OCI global
infrastructure where we're going to look
at all the bigger things that run the
OCI platform and the first thing we're
going to look at is called regions so a
region is a geographically distinct
location that has many data centers data
centers in OC are called availability
domains which we are going to talk about
shortly here and so I just want to
emphasize that I say a region is a
geographically distinct location the
Oracle documentation calls it a
localized geographical area
I think we're picking hairs here but on
the exam you might see it called a
localized geographical area just realize
that it's the same thing the idea is
it's just a part it's a place in the
world ok and as of the year 2020 OCI has
21 regions and they plan on having 15
more the three kinds of reasons you can
have are commercial so that's any
customer can launch a resource in these
regions governments so only governments
can launch resources in these regions
and then we have Azure connected so we
have some commercial regions that are
connected to Microsoft Azure which is
another cloud provider and it's similar
it's similar in terms of services and
stuff but they seem to work together
pretty well if you're still not sure
about what regions are I'll pull up the
website here in a moment but I just want
to show you a technical architectural
diagram and this is the first
architectural diagram of this course so
what we have here is a representation of
OSI ISO OCI there is the actual platform
and
we have a region because that's where
you would launch your servers and a
region can be any like a bunch of places
in the world so it could be in Toronto
or it could be in Tokyo so this one we
have one that is for Tokyo and inside
there we have an ad that's the the
actual data center and in that data
center we have our actual server okay so
that is a region and now we'll just hop
over to the website so you get a better
visual idea what a region is so I found
a world map here of all the regions for
Oracle and so the ones in red are the
ones our commercial desert the regions
you'll be able to launch your resources
within then you have government regions
those are the ones in blue as you can
see they only have two currently here in
North America these government regions
exist because the government wants to
launch resources onto the cloud but they
need to meet certain requirements so
these data centers are highly
specialized for government regulations
so unless you work for the government
you're not going to be able to launch
resources within those regions then you
can see we have planned regions here so
that's just oracle saying hey we're
gonna have more servers soon so please
keep please make sure that you use
oracle there's also a j''r connected
regions but they're not showing up here
on this map so it's probably an Ashburn
in Phoenix so it's just not clear it's
very hard to find that graphic if you
want a full list of regions you can go
to the documentation here and here they
all are they have this region identifier
so that's what you're going to be used
to looking at and this is how you're
going to identify the regions but they
also have this thing called a region key
here so we have SDK and the L and etc
and it shows how many availability
domains those are the amount of data
centers within that region which we'll
talk about more later if you want to see
like actually how you switch regions
when you log into the actual provider
you'll be able to drop this down and
just switch the region that you are in
and then if we come over here just to
this page here this shows us that not
all services are available in every
single region so if you want to make
best use of all the Oracle services
they're always going to be available in
US East or us East one I bet they always
launch their new services there but just
be aware that
you might not have access to certain
services and it just could be a matter
of time for them to get the
infrastructure they need to be able to
run those services within your region
and so I think that is everything we
need to know about region so there you
go so let's take a look at a DS and a B
is a short for availability domain and
this is what OCI calls a data center and
a data center is the secured building
that contains hundreds of thousands of
computers on the right hand side we have
an example of an interior of the data
center and of course you wouldn't want
to have your dog there but I loved that
photo and all those wires on the
right-hand side are connected to a ton
of servers and so a region will
generally contain three data centers and
that is a very magic number and we'll
talk about that here in a moment but to
talk about data centers within a region
they are they need to be isolate from
each other so in diff completely
different buildings and the reason why
is that if one datacenter fails you have
other ones you can rely on but another
important thing is that the servers need
to are these data centers need to be
just close enough so they provide low
latency so those are two things they
need to be far enough away and isolate
so there's no disaster but close enough
that they're super super fast to talk to
each other and this comes down to our
last thing here which is it's a common
practice to run your work workloads in
at least three availability domains to
ensure services remain available in case
one or two data centers fail now when I
use that word workload that's the same
thing as if I said service or web
applications so you'll see me
interchange those words throughout this
course workloads service and web
application it generally means the same
thing and so here's an architectural
diagram of a region and in that region
we have three data centers so 81 82 83
and this architectural diagram is not
actually accurate because CA Toronto one
doesn't actually have three data centers
in that region so we said earlier that
generally there's three data centers but
Toronto is not one of them but you'll
see me use it as an example lot because
that is where I'm from but anyway so
this comes down to 180 regions so OCI
region's not all OCR regions have three
ATS and it's a common strategy for cloud
providers to initially launching new
region with only a single data center
add more later and I mean this isn't
great because if you want to work in
enterprise you have to meet that minimum
of having your workloads in three and
three data centers in a region but the
reason why OCI does this is because
they're trying to expand their business
as quickly as possible and so it's
important for them to open as many
regions and they promise they'll say all
will open more later down the road so if
we look at 180 regions in 380 regions
you'll see that the majority of oracle
regions only have one data center
there's only four regions that have
three data centers Germany London and
the states so in this list we're
actually only listening to 16 and we
said earlier there were 21 regions the
reason why there's only 16 in this list
is because we're only listening the
commercial regions I'm not sure about
the government regions but that's the
reason this is a bit more short but
there you go that's 80s and that's it so
let's take a look now at F DS and f DS
is short for fault domains and fault
domains is what OCI calls a logical data
center so what is a logical data center
it's a virtual or abstract data center
within a physical data center so the
reason why we have these logical data
centers is that the physical data center
which we call an availability domain
contains resources such as
infrastructure hardware and some of
those resources are logically grouped
together and made accessible to you
within the Oracle console and the reason
why is that by having an abstraction on
top of our physical data center this
allows our cloud provider to put layers
in between the in between such as
logical security controls monitoring
tools and fault tolerance and you'll
notice fault tolerance is emphasized
because that's the whole point of fault
domains and the whole point of fault
domains is that it's to isolate
groupings of hardware
in a data center so that they don't
share a single point of failure so here
is a diagram and again we're using CH
Ron 2/1 which again only has a single
region but for whatever reason I'm
listening to but within that data center
the the ad here right the the
availability domain we have two fault
domains and so the idea is like imagine
there was a fire in the data center and
so only half of the data center burnt
down and if you happen to have your
servers in the second fault domain then
you know they would remain operational
so this is just another way to reduce or
to improve the fault tolerance of your
systems and so that's the purpose of a
fault domain hey this is Andrew Brown
from exam pro and we are now looking at
OC 8 concepts and this is just a short
section talking about some of the
terminologies about that are in OCI and
so the first one we want to talk about
is the console and so if you're gonna
hear me mention the word console
multiple times and when I say that we're
referring to the simple and intuitive
web-based user interface that you can
use to access and manage the Oracle
cloud infrastructure so see this this is
the console anytime we were doing
anything in Oracle whether it's
launching a server deleting a database
or creating a new user we're using the
console so just be aware of what that is
[Music]
so let's look at the concept of tenancy
so when you first create your OCI
account Oracle will create you a
tendency by default and this is where
all your resources are going to go
initially and what a tendency is it's a
secure and isolated partition within oci
where you create organize and administer
your cloud resources a tendency is also
known as a root compartment and a
compartment is also another OCI concept
which we'll cover here shortly but you
can see that we can have compartments
within our compartment and our root
compartment is also known as a tenancy
[Music]
so now let's take a look at the concept
of compartments so a compartment is a
logical collection of related resources
that can be accessed only by certain
groups that have been given permission
by an administrator and so a resource
would be a cloud service so that could
be an instance or vcn or block volume so
the majority of cloud services in OCI
and so if you want to create
compartments you just press create
compartment and you can create a bunch
there and so we can see we have three in
this example one thing we want to note
is that it when you first create your
account oracle creates you a tendency on
signup and this is known as a root
compartment and that holds all of your
cloud resources by default that's where
they're gonna go
you can only and some other additional
things about compartments you can nest
them and you can have some six levels
deep you can add and delete them
whenever you like compartments are not
region specific so you can group
resources cross region resources can be
easily moved to other compartments you
can department resources can interact
with each other you can apply policies
to compartments to determine user access
and you can associate a compartment to a
budget for cost analysis so you can see
compartments have a lot of functionality
behind them but generally you know
that's what we do so now we're going to
take a look at OC IDs so OC IDs is short
for Oracle cloud IDs and this is a
unique ID assigned by Oracle to your
cloud resources and the reason they do
this is so that you're able to easily
identify these resources within your
policies or maybe the API just so that
you can interact with them and so this
is the format of an OC ID so you have
the USC ID one the resource type the
realm the region the future use and
unique ID it's not so important for us
to go through all those all I want you
to take away from this is that it's a
unique identifier identifier for a
resource here's an example of a tendency
and you can see it's very long and
complicated and then here's one for an
instance so a server so that's OCI
[Music]
so now I want to talk about how do we
get programmatic access to OCI so the
main way is through an API application
programming interface and this is a way
to interact with cloud services
pragmatically and this concept of API is
not specific to Oracle it's for all
cloud providers or applications and so
the API is how you would get access to
it but there has to be some vehicle or
mechanism to interact with the API so
one way it would be to use a command
line interface also known as the CLI and
this is a terminal program that you
could use you'd have to have Linux and
you'd have to have a terminal to access
it but if you wanted to easily do it if
you didn't have a Linux machine Oracle
has a web browser-based terminal called
cloud shell and that's gonna let you
interact with the CLI and it's gonna
already be pre authenticated so it's
already gonna have the access access
tokens to allow you to start interacting
with cloud services program eclis
another way would be to use the software
development kit also known as an SDK and
so this allows you to use common
programming languages so that you can
build applications that interact with
OCI and they currently support Java go
Ruby and Python and the way you'd
actually get programmatic access is that
you'd have to have an API public key and
private key so you generate this on your
own and you would upload it into Oracle
some other cloud providers you just
press a button it generates it for you
but with Oracle you have to generate
them yourselves and upload them
yourselves so there you go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are starting off a new section
which is the core services for OCI and
starting with the first and most
important one are the computing services
so first in our list we have virtual
machines so virtual machines is a
multi-tenant server running a hypervisor
layer so the idea here is you choose
your OS virtual image and you launch
your server you share the cost with
other customers so you save so anytime
you launch a server this is generally
the go-to server that you're going to
want to launch because it's the most
cost effective and the most flexible if
you don't understand what a hypervisor
layer is right now do not worry we're
going to talk about it shortly next we
have container engines so this service
for OC I is basically docker as a
service it allows you to run docker
containers on a virtual machine so this
is a very popular for micro service or
containerized architecture then we have
the OCI functions service so this is
service compute you just upload your
code and the cloud provider takes care
of the rest so the code is designed to
run for a short period of time and you
choose a managed container with a
runtime so if you have Ruby code you
upload your Ruby code I don't know if
they support Ruby but as an example you
would upload your code able to run it
and then it would stop but the idea is
that it's a lot more cost-effective than
a virtual machine and it's just also a
lot less responsibility for you then we
have dedicated virtual hosts so this is
a single tenant server that is running a
hypervisor layer where you can run
multiple virtual machines you don't
share the server with anyone else so you
get greater security and performance are
guaranteed but you can still run your
own virtual machines and last on our
list is bare metal so bare metal is a
dedicated server that has no hypervisor
layer so bare metal allows you to
provide your applications with direct
access to the processor and memory
resources an underlying server and this
is suited for specialized workloads
where the hypervisor would hinder
performance so some people they just
really want the original server you know
like they there's nothing on it and they
can configure it and they have that
option so remember earlier when we
talked about the evolution of servers
and I said that everybody's still using
everything well this is
that perfect example of that but let's
get more into the details as to you know
why we would want to use one type of
setup over another so now what I want to
do is help you decide which computing
service you should choose based on the
level of control or responsibility you
want to have the more the more control
you have over security configuration the
more responsible you're gonna have the
more time it's going to take for you to
maintain and spend money on those
resources so if you can let OCI do it i
definitely recommend it for you and
across the top we have bare metal
dedicated virtual hosts VMs vm is short
for virtual machine you'll hear me use
the abbreviation a lot in this course
container engines and functions and so
the first thing we want to look at is
your code so you're always responsible
for your code no matter what computing
service that you choose so just be aware
of that
the next is app container and what I'm
saying container I'm using this in a
very generalized term maybe we're
talking about containers as being the VM
or whatever but the point is is that all
the way up to functions is the only time
that OCI is responsible for it so if you
want to use containers or sorry if you
do not want to manage your container use
the functions the next layer is your
runtime a runtime is it's like your
setting so your environment variables
common libraries directory structure
networking neighbors all those sorts of
configurations on your OS and so you
have a less control when you're using
the container engine service or the
functions service next is your operating
system and so for your operating system
if you're using bare metal dedicated
virtual hosts or VMs you have more
control over what OS you choose then
down below we have virtualization so
virtualization is being taken care of
for you by OCI with the VMS and the
dedicated regional host
there is no virtualization on bare metal
so if you do want to have it you're
gonna have to add that hypervisor layer
yourself so there you go that is the the
idea with level control for computing
services
[Music]
so next on our list is storage services
starting with block volume so block
volume I like to think of it as having a
local virtual hard drive where you
choose the hhd or SSD this is what
you're going to be primarily using when
you're using your virtual machines
you're going to want to be using a block
volume attached to it
the next thing we have is local nvm II
nvme is a transfer protocol for SSD that
allows the drive to operate very very
efficiently I had to look this one up
but I'm sure people that make video
gaming computers or that do video
editing really do care about using MVM
II because it gives you extremely fast
performance then you have file storage
and so file storage is when you're using
a file system such as NSF version 3 this
allows multiple connections to the same
storage device at the same time which is
really nice when you're doing cloud
stuff and you need something to have the
same files then you have object storage
so object storage is service storage and
you can upload as many files as you like
and it scales without worrying about
running out of space or data loss
because generally the data you put into
object storage is highly available it'll
be replicated across multiple data
centers then we have archive storage
this is long-term cold storage and this
is when you need to keep files around
for a very long period of time that you
might infrequently access and so the
idea is you wouldn't want to put them in
object storage because you know the idea
is that it'd be more expensive so if you
if you never have to use them so let's
say you have to hold on to records for
the next seven years for like let's say
for taxes you'd want to put them an
archive storage so they're not costing
you more money so I want to talk a bit
more about storage services and just
make a bit more clear the difference
between blocked vs. file versus object
because those are the main three that
you need to be thinking about so let's
first talk about block storage and so
Oracle service is called block volume
and this is where the data is split into
evenly split blocks and the data is
directly accessed by the operating
system and there's only support for a
single write volume so if you have
multiple virtual machines you're going
to have multiple block volumes and
you're not
to be able to share that volume with
other machines or at least if you do
it's not very easy and this s is just do
with the fact that it's only the
operating system accessing it the
protocols that are being used here is FC
maybe is CSI or I scuzzy there's another
one there you don't really need to know
the transfer protocols but I'm just
trying to point out that a block volume
is directly accessed by the OS and only
supports a single write volume so you're
not sharing that drive with multiple VMs
or users next is file Sargent file
storage is stored with data and metadata
and so with this format you can have
multiple connections via a network share
so you can use protocols such as NFS or
SMB and so it's going to allow multiple
users or multiple VMs to access that
file system and it's gonna act as if
you're all on the same computer which is
really nice so it supports multiple
reads but when you are writing to a file
it will lock so if I'm writing on a file
then you can't access it until I'm done
with it last we have object storage so
object storage is stored with data
metadata and unique ID the protocols
were going to be using here is HTTP or
HTTPS and API the way you're going to
access these files is through the
internet so that's how you're gonna get
access to them the advantage of object
storage is there is no there is no limit
in terms of the size of the files or or
the amount of falsity that you store or
if there is they're very very high
you're not gonna be affected by them and
the last thing is that it supports
multiple reads and writes so there's no
lock so you aren't going to be hindered
if somebody is working with a file so
yeah those are your three solutions and
another thing that I don't have the
slide here but block volume is the most
expensive at scale and object storage is
the least expensive at scale so you know
the more you get to the server lists and
that object storage is a service service
the more cost-effective it gets
[Music]
okay so now we're gonna look at
networking services networking is
generally very complicated for any cloud
provider for the Foundation's
certification you don't need to know it
in great detail you just have to have
some practical knowledge of it so don't
worry if you don't know all the little
details here but let's go through it so
for networking services we've already
seen some of these earlier so the first
thing is region so a region is a
geographical location of your network
and so there's my line I don't usually
annotate very often but your region
would be here okay so we have CA Toronto
one and so that is a geographical
location the next is your availability
domain and remember it's a availability
domain is short for ad and this is a
data center for your 8 of those
resources so here we have the ad and so
this one is a d1 then you have your
fault domains this is a logical grouping
of your resources in a data center and
so there is our fault domain then you
have your vcn and vcn stands for virtual
cloud network you're definitely going to
want to know that one and I believe I
have a complete slide for a virtual
cloud network just to really make sense
of that and so it is here and that is
your that is a logically isolated
section of the OSI cloud where you can
launch your OCR resources then you have
internet gateway so internet gateway is
how you get access to the Internet so
there is the symbol for Internet gateway
you can see that it sits on the edge of
OCI and that's how it gets out to the
Internet
then you have subnets subnets is a
logical partition of an IP network into
multiple smaller network segments and
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in the next slide and this orange line
around here is that subnet but anyway
the easiest way to think of a subnet is
it's a slice of the VCM and then down
below we have a virtual firewall options
and so we have security rules and
network security groups and security
lists all I want you to take away from
this is that these three things
protect your your resources and so here
this icon here is a one of those
Kember which one it is I think it's a
network security group I'd have to
double-check but the point is is that it
represents a virtual fire rap firewall
that is protecting your server and
that's your server right there
so you know that's one part of
networking services and we'll hop on to
the next slide all right so we're on to
the second part of our networking
services the first one was really if
you're a cloud native or using it for
your own personal account and these
networking services are really for
enterprise or hybrid hybrid architecture
but we still need to learn them we don't
need to remember them in granular detail
but you should generally know what they
do so the first is service gateway so
here's service gateway and what service
gateway does is it creates a secure
tunnel that keeps traffic within the OCI
network so here is the symbol over here
for service gateway and what you're
seeing is that it screamed a secure
tunnel to this the service which is
object storage and the reason why we
want a secure tunnel is that generally
there are certain services especially
serverless services where they're not
part of your vcn they're just they're
just in the global OCI account and if
you want to access them they have to go
out to the internet so this server would
go out to the internet and go around and
come back in and you do not want it to
leave OCI because as soon as you leave
OCI out to the internet it's no longer
secure so by using service gateway we
can keep the traffic within OCI so it
never leaves that's super important for
people that are operating the enterprise
then you have nat gateway so in that
gateway is down here this is the sim
there's actually no symbol for it so I
made my own and what nack gateway does
it allows private a private subnets the
resources or servers in a private subnet
will reach out to the Internet
this orange dotted line is our subnet
and so it doesn't have any access to the
Internet and so let's say we wanted to
grab packages or software to update the
server we have to get out of the
internet we'd use a NAT to do that so
that's done the next is IPSec VPN so a
virtual private network is a way of
creating a secure tunnel over the
internet from your on-premise into
Oracle cloud and again any time we leave
out to the internet it's a dangerous
territory so we want to secure that
action and that's what we're gonna use
for that the next is fast connect it's
just like IPSec VPN but the difference
is that it's a dedicated a dedicated
secure connection to your on-prem to
cloud what that means it's going to be
really really really fast so not only is
it going to be secure but it's gonna be
super fast and that could matter to an
enterprise because they want the
experience to be just as fast as their
on Prem data center then we have dynamic
routing gateway so dynamic routing
gateway is a virtual router that
provides a path for private traffic
between your vcn and outside network so
to actually connect the Fast connect or
IP or VPN we need this DRG which is that
Virtual Private router if it's confusing
to you it's confusing to me I don't ever
set these things up but I know that it's
a virtual router and I know that it
creates a connection into the vcn and
that's all you need to know - and the
last one here is VC and peering so
peering is the concept of connecting to
VC ends together and and treating them
as the same network so if you have a VC
n1 here and vcn to here then they can
peer they can this server can talk to
that server as if they're on the same
network so those are all the concepts I
wanted you to learn for networking
services I know it's super complicated
but just do your best because of the
foundation level knowing networking
stuff is not as important as the next
level so now let's take a look at VC
ends and subnets so VC n is short for
virtual cloud network it is a logically
isolated section of OCI where you can
launch OCR resources and so the way you
define a VC n is you have to choose a
range of IPs using a site or range and
it's not so important to know the math
behind cider range all I want you to
know is that it's a range of IPs so if
you chose 10.0.0.0 4/16 that 16 is
defining the size of the IP addresses
and that would give you 65,000 IP
addresses what does that mean it's like
if you want to launch 65 servers you
have enough IPS to launch 65,000 servers
and so there's the architectural diagram
of
of a of the OCI network with a region
and so there would be your vcn now the
thing is with the vc n is we wanted to
split it up into smaller logical
sections and that's where subnets come
into play so subnets is a logical
partition of the IP network into
multiple smaller network segments you
are breaking up your IP range for your
vc n into smaller networks and subnets
have a side arranged as well but the
side arranged has to be smaller than the
vc n side arranged because you're it's
like cutting up a PI it has to be
smaller you can't take the whole pie so
for the example here I'm using sided
range 10000 4/24 which would give us 256
IP addresses so it's a very small slice
out of art of out of our BC n now
subnets can either be public and so
subnets that are public are ones that
can reach the internet and you can see
that's where our server would be
launching to into the actual subnet or
if we wanted a a subnet where it cannot
reach internet we call that a private
subnet that doesn't mean that it can
never reach the internet it's just
generally it's not supposed to because
it's supposed to be secure but with Nats
and some other means that it can reach
the Internet let's talk about V CIN so V
CIN stands for virtual network interface
card and this enables an interface or
sorry an instance to connect to a vcn
and determines how the instance connects
with endpoints inside and outside the
vcn now remember an instance just means
a server so if you want your server to
be able to connect to other services you
need a you need a VCI n so without a V
CIA and your server would not be able to
communicate with the internet or other
networked cloud services in your vc n
and the reason we're talking about this
is because we're gonna be looking at
security lists and they're dependent on
v CI ends here but on the exam I don't
think they're gonna really be asking you
about v CI ends too much
[Music]
so let's take a look at our virtual
firewall options so the networking
surface offers two virtual firewall
features that both use security rules to
control traffic at the packet level and
those two are security lists abbreviate
as SL so this is the original firewall
feature from from the networking service
and secrete lists are associated with
subnets and the security rules apply to
VC ions in those subnets and that's why
we were talking about v CI ends because
security both of these really relate to
the those networking components what I
want remember cyclists are associated
with subnets then you have networking
security groups this is the new virtual
firewall I don't necessarily know if it
will replace the old one because they
both kind of have different use cases
but the NS G's are designed for the
application for months that have
different security postures so and its
user supported only for specific
services and as these are directly
associated with v CI ends regardless of
what subnet they are in so remember
cyclists are associate with subnets and
as G's are directly associated with the
v CI ends so now it's time to take a
look at the database services and oracle
is generally known for databases so they
do have a few options it can be a little
bit confusing because some services
especially in the console some some
services are not distinctly isolate from
each other but we'll work our way
through it and it'll make sense in the
end so the first one is vm DB systems so
vm standing for virtual machine DB
standing for database and so it's a
virtual machine running a managed oracle
database instance and it's gonna be back
to by block storage so this could also
be a MySQL database which we'll talk
about shortly when we go to the next
slide but it's just a virtual machine
and it runs Oracle for you and the
reason you might want to use this one is
that it has very fast provisioning or
this is the most general purpose
database that you will probably want to
use the next one is VM BM system so BM
is short for bare metal and so it
not running a virtual machine there is
no hypervisor layer so you get much
faster performance it uses fast local
storage so if if if you need a server
that or a database that is really fast
this is an option that you might want to
consider the next is Oracle RAC and so
this is this is I believe the virtual
machine it's just like the PMDB systems
but it is running in a cluster a cluster
meaning that it's running more than one
database so so you have two instances of
databases and they're sharing the same
disk but they're running on different
nodes and so if a node fails the
connections going to fail over to
another nodes this is a great way to get
higher durability which we talked about
in our sorry fault tolerance this is
better to have better fault tolerance
which we talked about with our cloud
technology concepts then you have X the
data DB systems the first time I've ever
heard of exadata but exadata is a
pre-configured combination of hardware
and software that provides an
infrastructure for running Oracle
databases so Oracle created their own
special combination I imagine that the
the the advantage here is that you have
extremely good performance for very
specific use cases I don't know what
those use cases are I don't think it's
going to matter on the exam if you if
you know but you just need to know that
exit data exit data DB systems is just
specialized infrastructure that gives
you great performance and last on our
list is autonomous so autonomous can be
autonomous shared or dedicated the
difference between one being multi
tenant or single tenant and this is for
automatically or sorry this database
does basically everything it will
automatically patch upgrade it will do
self-healing for bad data it's highly
available by default it's secure by
default so it's a fully managed database
it's gonna cost you a lot more money
than anything else on this list but it's
going to it's going to do all the work
for you so you know it just it you never
have to worry about this database so
there you go so I just want to go over
some of the database options because I
do find a bit confusing to know when
you're creating what type of database in
Oracle because they have some of the
options so if you were to create a DB
systems or dbvm systems
database option so that's kind of
redundant how I wrote there but you
could choose an oracle DB system so
that's the default and when you do you'd
have to choose an availability domain in
a virtual machine and a shape type a
shape type is just basically the VM like
how much power do you want the machine
to have like computing etc but you can
also create a MySQL database but what's
strange is that when you make the Oracle
one you don't choose a fault domain but
when you make one for my squall you can
choose a fault domain is this gonna be
on the exam no but I just wanted to
point it out that you know I was a bit
confused and this is what I observed as
being the difference and then we have
autonomous database options so when you
go to create your autonomous database
what you choose is between an OLTP and
an O L AP oh well ap is going to be your
data warehouse that's for reporting
analytics and large and infrequent
queries then you have OLTP that's
general-purpose small and and frequent
and frequent queries so oh oh Lt P or
transaction processing is what you're
gonna want for general workloads and
then if you're working with big data
you're going to want the data warehouse
1 then down below the next option you
choose is between shared infrastructures
so that's a multi-tenant or dedicated
that is single tenant then you can
choose a license so bring your own
license or you will use the license
included so again you know it's just
like these aren't generally separated
it's just like you go choose a database
and you make these choices whereas in my
my previous lecture there you saw that
it looked like all the services were
isolated so hopefully that clears that
up when you're in the console if you
feel
[Music]
so let's quickly touch on Oracle no SQL
and this is a service so you can have a
new SQL database so that it's a key
value store I'm sorry this slide is not
more attractive but they just have no
icons there's not a lot of information
on it but generally we should know what
a new SQL a databases and so the reason
you'd want to use NoSQL database over
the other databases is that if you need
to produce and consume data at a high
volume and velocity the all-school might
be for you if you require instantaneous
response time to match the user
expectations no SQL could be for you
it's developed with continuous evolving
data models and it can scale on demand
based on dynamic workloads so there's
just a point where relational databases
the the meet a point where it becomes
very difficult to scale you have to do
sharding and all these other things and
so then it becomes a point where you
want to move over to note school so just
think of no school being for at scale
and you know hopefully you don't get any
questions on it but I just want to
include it in there just in case so now
I just want to cover some cloud native
services but really this section is just
a bunch of Oracle services that might
show up on the exam and and so I need to
get you a bit familiar with them so the
first is Oracle API gateway this is a
comprehensive platform for managing
delivering and securing web api so if
you need to make a web api you're going
to use api gateway then there's oracle
streaming and justin's store continuous
high volumes data streams and process
them in real time if a question asks
something to be in real time
so now let's talk about cloud native
services but really what this section is
about is just getting you exposure to
more Oracle services that might show up
on the exam but you don't need to have
deep knowledge about them so the first
one is Oracle API gateway and this is a
comprehensive platform for managing
delivering and securing web api so if a
question asks about creating an API it's
probably it's probably telling you to
choose API gateway then there's Oracle
streaming this is when you ingest
in-store continuous high volumes a high
volume data streams and process them in
real time if the question is asking
about data streams or real-time events
then it's gonna be Oracle streaming
Oracle kubernetes container engine
okayyyyy is a managed service to run
kubernetes cluster if you see the word
kubernetes it's talking about oke then
there is Oracle registry o Cir and this
is a repository for your dr containers
if you need somewhere to store your
docker containers it's going to be in o
Cir then there's oracle notifications
it's a fully managed publish publish
subscribe service for reliable and
scalable message delivery so if the
question has to do something with
notifications pub/sub or message
delivery that's what it's going to be
the last one is Oracle integrations a
service to connect on-premise third
party to your o CI with pre-made
adapters for easy application
integration so if you need to connect
your on-prem to your o CI in a very
convenient way so Oracle integrations
might be the answer so we're on to the
billing and pricing section so let's
talk about pricing models so orful has
ways for you to save with the universal
credit pricing also known as Oracle you
see I'm a little bit confused by the
terminology because I don't know if it
applies to both their pricing models but
I'm gonna make mention of it because we
definitely need to know what Oracle UC
is or universal credit pricing is the at
least no of the terms and so the first
way you can pay is you can pay as you go
so PAYG most other cloud providers call
this on-demand so that's why I have it
there and so the idea is that if you
were to launch a server you're using
page you go there's no upfront
commitment you're billed based on hourly
consumption and you pay at the end of
the month the other way you could pay is
monthly flex and
so these are plans to save money and I
guess this is what uses the Oracle you
see so what you do is you make a
commitment so you say I'm gonna commit
for a minimum of 12 months and I'm gonna
commit at least a minimum of $1,000 per
month and that's gonna give me savings
between thirty to sixty five percent so
it's just a way if you're a larger
company and you know what you're gonna
be using you can definitely save a lot
of money up front there's also another
thing to factor in for pricing models
and that is bring your own license so
Oracle has been around for a very long
time and so people are running Oracle
products and software on their on their
on-premise data center and they might
want to bring those licenses over to
save money so if you bring on over those
licenses then you'll get the same
support contracts that you've already
agreed to if you don't have an existing
license shield just get one when you use
the Oracle cloud platform and the number
one thing that I want to emphasize
number one thing is that no matter what
region you're in the pricing is the same
so if you if you launch a server in
Tokyo it's going to cost the same in
Canada it's gonna cost the same in
Germany now why does the work will do
this they say it's because it's to keep
pricing simple I'm not sure if I I
believe that but I think it's just
they're a smaller provider and maybe in
the future they will start changing the
prices per region because if I'm a
consumer wouldn't I want the best price
I can get for that region and some
regions will be more cost-effective than
others but for whatever reason all
reasons are the same and that is
critical to know if you come from other
cloud providers this would be a surprise
to you because all cloud providers have
different pricing based on regions so
there you go
so I just wanted to quickly pull up the
Oracle website just to show you where
you can find pricing so I just searched
Oracle pricing and this will show you
pay-as-you-go universal credits so I
guess universal credits is really aren't
part of monthly flex I still don't
personally understand why they're called
universal credits it makes me think that
you can reuse them any unused amounts
can be rolled over to the next month
okay so there you go that's probably why
they call them universal credits I think
you have bring your own licenses if we
go over to this page here this is the
universal credit pricing you're gonna
come down
here and you're going to notice that
there is no Regents everything is very
standardized so whatever you're paying
for analytics it's the same no matter
what region you're in but that is the
page you go price and then that is the
monthly flex price which is interesting
because I would generally think that
this price would vary based on your
commitment whether it's one year or
three years so I'm not really sure about
that but what you need to know is that
with monthly flex you save that's all
that matters and then the last tab here
this is just another one because this is
a universal credit pricing but maybe you
want to look at the actual compute
pricing and so these are all the
computing servers here so this I think
this is their standard one so it's Oh
point zero three cents and point zero
three cents if you're ever wondering how
you would ever calculate your your
yearly clock or your monthly cost you
would just take this number here so I
would take that I would just put it up
into Google I would do at times and I
would say 730 hours and so the the base
server would cost you twenty one dollars
and and ninety cents that's how I always
calculate my monthly cost for servers
it's just seven thirty times the number
so there you go that is the pricing so I
want to show you one more thing here and
that is the cost estimator so if you
were to type in cloud pricing you're
gonna see this button here we're gonna
click into it and this is gonna help you
determine your cost so you saw me do the
math where I took the hourly computer or
the hourly compute and just times it by
730 but if you really need to compile
out your own report what you can do is
you can use their estimator here so we
can go here and just look for any kind
of service so we have infrastructure so
let's add a VM so we'll go ahead and hit
add and then it will say what kind of
compute we can scroll down here and say
we want to have one instance see where
it says pay use pays you go $63 and
there's just lots of things you can do
here so we would do that and I'm just
going to expand that so we have $63 I
could add an object store okay it says
$0 it's really based on our storage so
we'd have to go here and start saying
how much we'd use if we go to block
volume
this is in gigabytes let's say we had
100 gigs now we can see it's four
dollars so I just want you to be aware
that there's a cost Explorer and it will
show you your pay as you go and flex it
doesn't necessarily show you it has kind
of an estimate but even here it doesn't
give you a guarantee that it that is per
month I've never hit the buy here but I
would imagine that it just tells you to
make a new account so there you go and
you still have to set those up
individually so just because you acute
all those things up in the cost Explorer
doesn't mean that the that they would
create all those resources for you this
is just a quick way of figure out those
costs and you can download it as a PDF
so if you need to take it to your boss
then we can just open this up here it
will just take me a moment and so
there's that nice breakdown of all those
costs all right so there you go that is
the cost Explorer let's talk about data
transfer costs so for data transfer
anything that is coming into OCI network
it's going to be free so data in is free
we call that ingress any data that is
leaving the OCI network is gonna cost us
money we call that egress and so data
transfer within the same availability
domain is going to be free data transfer
between available domains in the same
region is going to be free data transfer
between regions will result in a charge
for data leaving the region but to
really make this clear I'm gonna give
you an architectural diagram to help
visualize this so here's the OCI network
anything outside of the USA Network will
consider the Internet imagine we have a
server running in a data center in a
region and so we have the internet and
we want to bring data into that server
so anything that's data in is going to
be free anything leaving the OCI network
we're going to be charged for so now
imagine we have another region and in
this region we have an availability
domain a data center and we have two
servers maybe they're in different fault
domains maybe they're different subnets
but the point is they're in the same
data center any data transfer between
them or it's going to be free now
imagine we have another data center
availability domain in that
region and we want to transfer data
between those two that's going to be
free because they're all in the same
region now imagine imagine we want to
get data from region the CA Toronto one
region to the AP Toronto one region so
if you send data out it probably would
have to go out to the internet and it
would and then it would come back in to
that other region so since it since even
though we want to keep it in OCI the
fact that it's another reason it has to
leave the internet and come back in its
gonna result in a charge now is there
some way to bridge data phone one region
to another I'm not sure there is a
service called service gateway but that
seems to be for cloud services but if we
could keep it all within OCI I believe
that it would be free but just remember
if it has to go out to the Internet it's
gonna cost money if it stays with an OC
I it's going to be free so I wanted to
get block volume pricing a bit of
emphasis because it's not as simple as
one metric that it's built on there's
actually two things you need to consider
with block volume pricing the first is
storage cost and the second is
performance cost so for storage cost
you're going to get billed based on how
what your store capacity is per month
and so it's going to be the most because
it's the same pricing in all regions
it's going to be zero to five five cents
per gigabyte I believe and then for
performance costs it's going to be based
on performance units per GPU per month
and so they actually have a breakdown of
3 so 4 0 V V P use it's zero dollars if
you need to use 10 VP VP use it's gonna
be its called balanced and it's point 17
cents if you need 20 V P use which they
call higher performance it's 0 34 cents
gigabyte per month if you're wondering
what VP use are it's called volume
performance units this thing is an
Oracle thing I'm not even sure exactly
how it works I couldn't find any
documentation on it I just want you to
know that there are three categories and
those are the prices and those are the
options and those are the two factors
you have to consider
[Music]
so in Oracle you can actually tag your
resources such as compute storage and
databases and tagging allows you to
filter resources so you could so can be
used in cost analysis to quickly
determine costs or if you just want to
find a group of resources but you're not
necessarily applying permissions to them
because compartments is for applying
permissions so what you would do is
let's say you will have a compute
resource you just say add a tag and then
what you do is you'd fill in a tag key
such as E and B and then a value such as
prod now there's a drop down there where
you have freeform tags and you have
Oracle tags Oracle tags only have
created on and created at like these two
time stamps have no idea what to use
those for looks like that is still in
active development but really you just
need to conceptually know what tags are
and so tags are a way of tagging
resources and allows you to use it for
cost analysis so now we're going to look
at the Oracle service called cost
analysis so OCI cost analysis will help
you visualize your ongoing costs you can
filter based on compartments tagged
resources and start and end date so if
you're in your free tier if you use the
service it will tell you how much of
your credits that you have used up so
far
so it's interesting because it's it's
$300 USD but since we use Canadian
dollars it shows that Canadian we get
$400 so I feel like where they're giving
us a little bit more because they
rounded it up to 400 and then if you
want to get a breakdown of your service
cloths on the right hand side they break
it based on categories so compute
storage networking and monitoring you
can see the exact resource underneath
and you get a nice little ticker graph
there and as we said in the prior video
you can use tags to help narrow down
costs but that is the cost analysis
[Music]
so now we're going to take a look at
usage reports so if you wanted to get a
granular view of your spending or find
ways to save you can download a CSV or
use the OCI API to access detailed
billing information and so the cost
report is automatically generated daily
for you and it's stored in an Oracle
owned object storage bucket so you just
go download that CSV it's gonna be based
on that 24-hour history so just
mentioning that 24 hours it generally
contains 24 hours of data although
occasionally a class report may contain
late arriving data that is older than 24
hours and if what would you do with the
CSV or the API data you'd have to put it
in your own visualization tool i mean
cost analysis kind of visualizes your
information for you but the idea of
having this raw data is so that you can
put it in your business intelligence
tool whatever tools that you want to use
for that but the fact is that you have
access to that raw so now let's look at
the free tiers and the free tiers is
what is going to be free so you can best
utilize Oracle before you want to start
spending money so we have the always
free and these are services that are
always free month over month so let's
talk about them right now so what you'll
get is two oracle autonomous databases
and again autonomous databases are great
because they're self-healing they're
highly scalable durable exterior so
really great database to choose then you
have to OCI compute VMs at 1-800 CPUs is
a Oracle term I'm not sure what it is
but that's how they calculate CPUs and
one gigabyte then you have to block
volumes for 100 gigabytes in total then
you have objects for up to 10 gigabytes
then you have archive storage up to 10
gigabytes at one load bouncer and all
data in is free so now and then
monitoring notifications and then also
OCI developers so this will automate CI
CD workflows I don't remember this is in
the interface but they say they
advertise it on their page and this
would be amazing because not having to
pay for a CI CD workflow sounds awesome
then you have the 30-day free trial so
when you sign up you get 300 USD credits
if you're in Canada it apparently it's
$400 so that's really nice and it's only
valid for 30 days so you
up to eight instances across all
available services you get up to five
terabytes of storage and those are the
two things you want to remember on the
tier now this isn't going to be on the
exam but if you want to know the full
list this is the full list so I actually
went through it I was really curious so
for compute you get three thousand five
hours 1.5 terabytes of storage for
storage you get five terabytes for
containers you get three thousand five
hundred hours and two terabytes of
storage for functions you get one
hundred and twelve invokes twenty
million gigabytes memory second
execution time for a load bouncer you
get three thousand five hundred hours
for fast connect you get one thousand
four hundred hours for Oracle WebLogic
server you get 1,700 hours 250 gigabytes
I have an asterisk there because they
give you two versions of Oracle WebLogic
server ones like 50 650 hours but it
wasn't clear what the difference was so
I'm just listing one of them here if you
want to use digital assistant which is a
chatbot you get a hundred ten thousand
requests if you want to use mobile Hub
that's for building out web applications
or mobile applications you get 110
requests if you need a wysiwyg to edit a
website you get four hundred seven four
thousand seven hundred hours if you want
to use their business intelligence tool
for analytics cloud you can use that for
four thousand seven hundred hours if you
want to use their machine learning
platform for data science you can use
that for four thousand seven hundred
hours there if you want to have a web
central portal so this is a secure
enterprise portal you get a thousand ten
hundred hours if you need application
integration so using OC integrations
there's two hundred and forty-eight
hours and if you need to use SOA base
api's which is super old but there's
some enterprises still using it you get
1700 hours so all this isn't on the exam
but it's great to know so you can best
utilize the platform
[Music]
so now let's talk about the Oracle
marketplace so Oracle marketplace our
managed VM images or stacks from
third-party vendors that are free or
paid that you can launch so a
third-party vendor you could be
launching maybe rocket chat which is
like a open source clone of slack maybe
you need GPU from Nvidia and there's
security ones and all sorts of ones both
from third party and even Oracle
themselves now if you want to know they
can either be free or paid or bring your
license so there's a different few
pricing options there and they have a
lot of different categories so you can
see analytics backup and data backup and
recovery developer tools operating
systems all sorts of things so if you
really want to get started very quickly
or you just you want to put the
responsibility on someone else to manage
those VMs the Oracle marketplace is a
great place to take a look at so now
we're gonna take a look here at the
Oracle SLA so isolate stands for service
level agreement and it's a guarantee of
performance availability manageability
of the of the Oracle platform and Oracle
defines it as those three categories and
if none this makes sense somewhere we're
gonna pull up the website to help
understand a little bit better so for
the availability SLA you have a 99.99%
uptime for compute running in one ad
region with measurements of reagent
unavailability we get ninety nine point
ninety five percent uptime compute in
multiple FDS those are fault domains in
a single ad availability domain and so
if we're for the availability when we're
looking at compute and notice it says
ten and twenty five ten and twenty five
that is the SLA breach I'm not exactly
sure what it means but you need to know
the numbers at least face value for the
exam so for reagent unavailability
you're going to see that it's 99.9
percent for reagent unavailability for
compute it's ninety nine point nine but
for block volumes it's ninety nine and
then for availability domains
unavailability at ten and twenty five we
get that 99.95 percent and the 99 which
is described up in the in that area
above right now for some other server
is under availability for object storage
and fast connect its 99.9 and 99% for
10% and 25%
respectively you're gonna see those
numbers repeated so there's just that
one exception with computes that it's a
bit more complicated now looking at the
manageability SLA s what we have here
for compute block volumes and databases
is ninety nine point nine for all for SL
a breach of ten percent and now you
member sent for SL a breach of twenty
five percent then for performance SLA s
for compute block volumes and database
it's 99.9 percent for ten percent and
SLA breach for twenty five percent so
you've seen a bit of a pattern here so
the thing I want you to remember is that
if the SLA breaches ten percent with the
exception availability compute it's
going to be 99.9 percent and for breach
of 25 percent it's gonna be 99 percent
so you know just have that in
consideration so here I am at the oracle
website pulling up the SLA agreements
and I just wanted to show you all these
all the numbers that I was getting that
information for you there so you can see
that it's broken down by service and
there are these measurements we didn't
cover the measurements because they're
not gonna be not gonna show up an exam
so hard to remember and all you really
know is like what at 10 percent or 25
percent what are the percentages that is
the guarantee of uptime but you can see
here for availability we have regional
availability availability domains API
error rate for manageability it's all
API error rate for performance its disk
i/o ops and network performance and then
there are some fa Q's here which should
not show up on the exam but they are a
bit interesting to read through if you
are curious but yeah there you go I just
wanted to make sure that I could point
you to this resource if you wanted to
read a little bit more about
[Music]
so let's talk about service limits for a
moment here so when you sign up for OCI
a set of service limits isn't configured
for your tenancy and the service limits
is the quota or loans of set on
resources so you're gonna actually have
hard limits of how many servers you can
spin up and utilize some things your -
so for example your tenancy is allowed a
maximum number of compute instances per
ad a lot of times you can only have two
at the start expecially when you're in
your sandbox these limits are generally
established with Oracle sales
representatives when you purchase OCI if
you do not establish limits with your
Oracle sales rep or if you signed up
through the portal default or trial
limits are set for your tenancy which is
probably the case for you those limits
may be increased for you automatically
based on your resource usage and account
standing you can request a service limit
increase so that is the key thing you
want remember you can request a service
limit increase if you cannot spin out
more servers so let's talk about support
for OCI so from what I could tell they
call it premier support and from the
only part of information I thought was
valuable to say was that they have rapid
resolution for 24/7 access to the Oracle
knowledge-based technical support and
ASR priority service request handling
remote diagnostic with to our on-site
hardware service and if you're in the
Oracle console there is a live chat and
I actually opened it up to ask what
these support plans were and I literally
was asked what do you mean and then they
said you should go contact a sales rep
to get a quote so it's strange because
in the exam guide says you're supposed
to know the support plans but the
support plan is go call a support rep
and I can't imagine anyone would do that
so this is all that I know will pull up
the support premier page here in a
moment just to see if we can see if
there's anything else that is
interesting to look at so I've gone here
and I've opened up Oracle support and
this is the only support that I can find
that is relevant to premier or sorry to
Oracle cloud and so they say find out
more about premier support and then here
we get a bunch of information that
doesn't really tell us anything
you know there's software and systems
and things like that so it's I'm not
particularly sure in terms of what they
offer support I imagine because their
enterprise you do have to call them and
find out but yeah just if you are
curious and you want to poke around and
see if you can find something else that
I didn't there you go so let's take a
look at the shared security model and
this is a very important concept to
understand because it tells you what
Oracle's responsible for and what you
the customer are responsible for in
terms of securing your workloads and
data so OCI is going to be responsible
for all the manage software and services
that they offer so that could be compute
storage databases and networking that is
not the full spectrum of services but
those are the the core four that I
always say that is the ones that they
are responsible for then you have your
hardware in your global infrastructure
so the regions they're responsible for
the data centers they're in there the
availability domains those are the data
centers themselves and then the physical
security of those data centers so you
know if it's hardware or if it's the
location or the IT people that manage
that infrastructure OCI is gonna take
care of that for you now is the customer
you are responsible for the
configuration of managed services or
third-party software so if you are using
a particular platform or application or
let's say you're creating new users or
and you're giving them permissions in in
I am it's your responsibility configure
those correctly and if you make them as
configuration it's going to be on you
then there's the configuration of the
virtual infrastructure and systems so
this could be the virtual operating
system that you have the virtual
networking that you have to configure or
the firewalls that you configure at your
networking level then next we have
security configuration of data so if you
have data you have to decide whether you
need to use client-side data encryption
a lot of cloud services will let you
check box that on and they might not be
checked box on by default so you've got
something have to double check then
there is server-side encryption then
there is protecting your network traffic
so that is putting Services Inc and
or monitoring tools to make sure that
you're monitoring the traffic that is
going through your environment and then
last but not least but the most
important is customer data you are
responsible for the customer data so any
data that you put on the platform you
have to make sure that it is secure so
that is the shared security model so now
let's talk about I am so I am stands for
Identity and Access Management and it's
a service that lets you control who has
access to your cloud resources and so
there are some components of iam that we
need to know of the first one our users
so when you create your Oracle account
you're gonna want to create users so
people have access to your Oracle
resources so a user would be an
individual employee or system that needs
to manage or use OCI resources then you
have groups so groups is a collection of
users who all need the same type of
access to set to to a set of resources
or compartments then you have dynamic
groups so dynamic groups is a special
type of group that contains resources
that match rules that you define if this
is not clear don't worry we're gonna go
through how to make a policy and this
will make it very clear and then we have
policies so this is a language that
defines permissions so if a user group
or dynamic group or compartments should
be allowed to access specific OCR's
resources within your account and one
thing I want to note that if you've ever
used any other cloud provider OCI is a
bit different in that you don't when you
create a resource or a user a group you
don't assign at the time of creation a
pre created policy you just create the
policy and it's in effect and this
really confused me because I was looking
forever
in the class of saying like AB you sign
it and so you just create the policy and
it's in effect so hopefully that will be
clear as we work our way through this
stuff
[Music]
so what I want to do now to really help
you understand IM policies I just want
to show you some common examples of what
that language would look like so this is
the language or syntax so you have this
allow subject - verb resource types in
location where conditions and we're
going to be going through all of these
little bracketed areas so that you
really understand but I just want to
show you some common examples first so
let's say you wanted to allow users to
analyze the costs for your team so you
do allow you'd say the the budget team
group is allowed to read only the usage
reports which is the resource type in
the tendency so that's our route
component next we have letting database
admins manage DB system so we're going
to allow the database admin groups to
manage the database family so any type
of database within Oracle in our
Tennessee our root account or root
compartment then we have let users
download objects from the object storage
buckets so we are going to allow group
object readers to read buckets in
compartments in the compartment called a
B whatever a B means so those are the
common policy examples but I just want
to show you that Oracle has a huge list
of policy examples on the on their
website so I'm just gonna pull that up
here in a moment so here are those
common policies I was talking about and
I actually pulled all those examples I
showed you from this list so you here's
a big big list so if you're never sure
what it is that you need to write in
here you can go here so lets users
create a volume group and they'll
explain where to create the policy and
what it would do but there's examples
for you so I just wanted you to be aware
that there was this big large list and
all you had to do is Google common
policies to find it
[Music]
so I'm gonna really help you understand
how policies work by looking at the
autonomy of a policy so what we're gonna
do is we're going to work through I
don't know what they call those nouns or
actions but all those brackets we're
gonna look at the examples of what we
can do there so you have a better idea
how you can use these policies do you
have to know how to write policies for
the exam
no but it's a very good practical skill
and it's good to learn it at the
foundational level so that's why we're
doing it so the first thing we're going
to look at is the subject so a subject
could be anything in your system so if
you wanted to specify everything you do
any user or you could specify I am group
name or ocid so it could be group
developers or group ID and the ocid for
that group that you want and then you
could specify dynamic groups so it's the
same thing as a group name you just say
a dynamic group tagged prod next we have
verbs so a verb could be either inspect
read use or manage and so if you want to
only allow someone to list resources we
would use inspect and OCI recommends
this is only for third-party auditors if
you had only want to get people read
access you do read and that would be
generally for internal auditors if you
wanted to give someone the ability to
read and update but not delete or create
resources you would use use and that
would be great for junior developers but
they just say developers and if you want
the ability to recreate update or delete
so be basically be able to do anything
you would set it as managing so that
would be your administrators next we
have resource types so if you want to
specify all resource types you would
just say all resources if you want you
to specify individual types such as only
access to buckets or only access to
route tables or only access to a
particular type of servers than you do
individual types but sometimes
individual types can be a bit cumbersome
so you might want to include everything
within a category which they call family
so maybe you want to say all types of
databases they're all types of servers
or all types of storage volumes so
database
would be all databases there that you
could put in there next would be the
location so this could be the tenancy so
that's your root compartment maybe you
want to specify a single compartment
such as compartment development or
compartment production or maybe you want
to specify based on the compartments
ocid and then last is conditions and we
have a lot of options here for
conditions so we could match based on a
strings that we could say we're target
group name equals staging you could say
it you could match based off a red X so
we only want to match target groups that
have a customer and then we have not so
this could be target group name so as
long as it's not beta then we won't use
the beta one then you can do also that's
where you can actually have multiple
statements condition statements so you
have one where it's its developer but
you don't want to be production and then
you have any so this could be when any
of the statements are true so if you
don't want it to be project a and we
don't want it to be project B so maybe
wanted to be project C so you know
hopefully that gives you a bit of an
idea on how to construct a policy but
you know to really understand they're
gonna have to get some practical
knowledge in there so now let's talk
about MFA and MFA is short for
multi-factor authentication it is a
security control where after you fill in
your user name email and password you
have to use a second device such as a
phone to confirm that it's you login why
would you want this well MFA protects
against people who have stolen your
password so if someone gets your
username and password how would you know
that
like how does the system know if it's
actually you and so this additional step
when you're dealing with cloud
infrastructure you definitely want to
have MFA turned on and you can turn MFA
on in most platforms so it whether it's
you're using AWS Oracle DCP or even if
you're using Facebook you can turn it on
so the way it works is you have your
your login so my email my password and
then what you do is you'd have a app
installed in your phone that is for MFA
and it would give you a code so the code
here would be four three nine six nine
one and you'd have to enter that code
back into like as
second step after your login and that
would make sure 100% that it is is you
who is logging in because the person who
stole your password doesn't have your
phone so they don't have that second
factor so the first factor is your email
and the second factor could be a device
such as your phone that has MFA
installed on it another device you could
use is called an EB key and so if you've
ever turned on MFA on Facebook it's
really annoying because you have to pull
out your phone unless you're already on
your phone but a new B key is is looks
like this little flash drive and you
leave it plugged in your computer and it
automatically enters in the second step
for you so that it's just as easy as
logging in and a great thing about this
key is you can just take it with yous so
a lot of people will put it around their
neck on a chain but that is what MFA is
[Music]
so now we're going to look at the
concept of Federation so Federation
identity is the ability to enable users
from one domain to securely access data
or systems of another domain without the
need of a redundant user administrator
if you're looking at that word domain
and wondering what it means domain could
just mean like your office and then
another domain would be like Oracle
cloud so the idea is that your office
has given you a username and password to
login to your your your office network
and you want to use those credentials
other places so let's give an example as
to why this would be useful so if you're
a large company and you purchase
multiple commercial and enterprise
software products or services such as
Oracle cloud wouldn't it be convenient
if the employee only had to log into
their work computer and they had access
to all these software products and
services without having to log it again
that concept is called single sign-on so
single sign-on is technology that
enables users to authenticate without
the need to log in or have separate pair
of credentials to third-party systems
another concept we need to know is I DP
so identity identity provider so
identity provider is a trusted provider
of your user identity that lets you
authenticate to access other services so
identity provider could be Microsoft
Active Directory if you're in the
enterprise world you've definitely heard
of Active Directory also abbreviated as
ad
okhta octa I don't know how to pronounce
it but that is an enterprise identity
provider but even Facebook is an
identity provider if you've ever went on
a website it says login with Facebook
that is an identity provider Facebook is
providing your identity so that you can
gain access to things other ones could
be Amazon Google Twitter github LinkedIn
and even oracle has their own it's
called oracle identity cloud service so
those are the three things you need to
understand what is the Federation
identity single sign-on and an IDP let's
talk about encryption or security for
the storage of our data and so for data
we have block volume file storage object
storage and then any database service
and so let's walk through this stuff so
for block volumes by default we're gonna
get encryption at rest so if you create
a block volume file storage or object
storage your data at rest is already
encrypted so that's data that is just
sitting on that drive on the server it's
encrypted then you have encryption in
transit that means when the data leaves
the actual storage device to go to a
server or whatever is that traffic
encrypted by default and it is for a
block volume and file storage you can
also bring your own keys so the thing is
is that for encryption at rest or in
transit you're going to be using some
kind of encryption key but if you have
you want to bring your own you can
definitely do that for block volume and
file storage and then for object storage
if you want to also be able to secure
your buckets bucketz is what they call
folders for object storage you can make
a private bucket and then for database
services is a bit different they have
TDE
data safe and database vault and if
you're wondering what those are we'll
talk about them right away so TDE is
transparent data encryption it's a
technology employed by markes off IBM
and Oracle to encrypt database files
then you have Oracle data safe is it's a
security control that monitors sensor
data such as OCI databases so it's not
exclusive to the database service but
our database services but that's what we
generally use it for and then you have
Oracle database vault so this restricts
access to
specific areas in your Oracle database
from any user including users who have
administrative access so there you go
and we'll talk a little bit more about
data safety so we briefly mentioned at
rest and in transit encryption but I
didn't really explain to you what those
ARS let me tell you what they are right
now
so at rest encryption address encryption
is securing data that is not moving
encrypting a hard drive would be
considered at rest encryption so you'd
use something like a key pair to encrypt
your data and a cryptographic algorithms
such as a e25 six but the key thing
there when you take away is that at rest
encryption is when you're securing data
what it's not moving then there's in
transit encryption and this is ensuring
your data that while it's moving from a
location to another location that it's
secure and if we were using in transit
encryption a protocol like SSL HTTP or
TLS would be used SSL is very common if
you've ever seen that little lock in
your web browser that is using SSL so
there you go those those two turn
[Music]
so let's talk about Oracle's data safe
service so Oracle data safe is a unified
control center for your Oracle databases
and what it looks like is this it's a
bunch of graphs and it gives you a very
clear picture of the security of your
actual databases so some things that it
can do it helps you understand the
sensitivity of your data evaluate risks
to your data mass if you need to mask
sensitive data you can do that you can
implement and monitor security controls
it has access or accesses user security
it monitors user activity and addresses
compliance requirements so this is very
interesting because I've yet to see such
a service on AWS or other providers so
you know Oracle is known for databases
and so this is one of the stronger
services they have in their in their
cloud so you know that's dated
[Music]
so let's talk about compliance programs
so if you want to sell to an enterprise
company or a government body they will
not buy your software unless it is
secure and so the question I pose to you
is how are you going to meet their
security compliance requirements so
they'll say we'll only do business with
you if you are at NIST 853 compliant so
that would be daikon there P I PDA
compliant that is a government
compliance program or HIPAA compliant so
HIPAA would be if you want to do
medicine it stands for health something
something American something and then
you have FIPS 140 - 2 compliant and this
is the way you handle encryption keys so
the idea is that there's all these
compliance programs and OCI is compliant
with them so if you do need to meet
these comply
compliance programs to get the business
of the governments or large enterprises
that is one of the strong advantages of
the cloud and I'll see if I can pull up
a page that shows all the compliance
programs on their website so here i'm on
the oracle website here i just search
for compliance programs or up here it
says cloud infrastructure compliance and
these are all the compliance programs
that they are meeting on their platform
so their infrastructure meets those
requirements so we have sox system
organizations controls one two three we
have one for the united kingdom cloud
security principles there's that
canadian one we saw they have a bunch so
hip HIPAA so Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability Act I
thought one was called America American
in there but it is an American act then
we have GDP are you we have FedRAMP but
you don't need to know the names of all
these it's good to know what HIPAA is
it's good to know what DCI PCI DSS
payment card industry data security
standards so if you're handling credit
cards online you generally need to be
PCI DSS compliant but yeah this is just
and I just showing you all these
compliance programs and I feel like you
could expand this and would tell you a
bit more it will tell you what the
program is about and what infrastructure
actually is meeting those requirements
so hopefully that
you an idea what compliance programs are
and why you carry shaker bow let's talk
about OCIE vault so osya volt makes it
easy for you to create and control
rotate a cryptic keys used to encrypt
data on OC i/o CI vault was previously
known as OC I key management or I think
they abbreviated as kms at least that's
what I think so just be aware if we're
talking about vault or key management
it's the same thing
o CI vault is a multi-tenant cloud HSM
if you're wondering what an HSM is HSM
stands for hardware security module it's
a piece of hardware designed to store
encryption keys and the reason why you
want to use a cloud HSM or a hardware
scream ah Zhu Liz that meets a
compliance program such as FIPS 140 - -
so we talked about compliance programs
prior and this would be a way to be
compliant with this program and so and
yeah the key thing here is that it's
multi-tenant so that means multiple
customers are sharing the cost if you
had to buy that piece of hardware
outright it's at least a thousand
dollars just for the hardware so you
could see how this is extremely cost
effective using OCI vault and you're
still compliant so let's talk about OS
management so it is a oracle service
that allows you to manage update and
patch your virtual machines operating
systems running on your Oracle cloud so
I like to think of us at management as a
toolbox for your VM so that's an easy
way to remember what it is so let's talk
about the features of OS management and
what it can do for you so one thing you
can do is it can search install and
remove Linux packages for you it can
search a faculty or a facility that you
can use to check individual CVE so
common vulnerabilities and exposures to
determine level exposure in your tenancy
so exposure meaning like as someone
trying to do malicious things like
trying to exploit security
vulnerabilities within your VMs then you
have software sources this is specific
to Linux but you can add or delete
software sources to provide packages to
instances to track available updates to
those pack
so it's not necessarily the installation
or removing or searching packages it's
the the sources of those packages then
you have managed instance groups this
enables you to group your instances
together for updates the purpose of this
would be like let's say you want to
apply patches to this set of servers you
can do that you can schedule jobs so you
can execute one time a single job so
let's say you wanted to download the
application logs because you need to
debug a problem on your production
server then you have work requests this
is just like scheduled jobs so you
execute a job but it's based on a
schedule so maybe every every day you
want to backup some very specific system
files and the last thing is you're gonna
get metrics and alarm so you can create
alarms such as when it's time to apply a
security update so that is OS management
[Music]
well let's talk about DDoS protection on
OCI
so before we do let's make sure we
understand what DDoS is so a DDoS attack
is a malicious attempt to disrupt normal
traffic by flooding a web site with
large amounts of fake traffic and so I
have a nice little diagram to show you
here so imagine you have a server and
imagine it's not on Oracle or any other
cloud providers just you have it
somewhere hosted and somebody decides
that they want to attack you they want
to flood you with a bunch of traffic so
they have their own server you don't
know where it is but they have that
server and what they do is they can
control multiple remote servers which we
might call slaves and what these servers
are going to do is they're going to send
fake traffic so they're gonna pretend
each server could pretend that they're a
thousand people and so if you have a you
know 20 servers retained they're each a
thousand then you send out all those
fake traffic over the internet and as it
goes over the internet it's a bit harder
to figure out where that traffic's
coming from and all those IP addresses
are spoofed anyway so we have no idea if
the IPS are really real and then you get
that flood of traffic and when you get
all that traffic hitting your server it
makes it to become unavailable it
becomes unavailable because it can't
handle the amount of traffic that's
coming in it's like imagine you're
getting lots of phone calls you can only
handle so much at a given time it's so
real you just can't reach your website
and that's what a DDoS attack is but by
having
your server just within OCI and the OCI
network you automatically get built-in
support for a DDoS protection so there's
different types of DDoS so four layers
three and four it's gonna protect a guns
flood attacks for layer seven you'd use
a laugh or some other tools we're not
gonna really talk about the layers too
much here but I just want you to know
that there's built-in DDoS protection
when you use your server on OCI so let's
take a look at what a Web Application
Firewall does so OCI has their own is
called OSI I laugh and that protects
your web app against common web exploits
so oh say laughs it's between your
server and incoming traffic and filters
out HTTP traffic this is a known as
layer seven I know I'm not talking too
much about the layers you just need to
know that it's layer seven and it
decides that it is unwanted based on
managed or custom configured rules so
OCI has rules that are gonna say this is
bad traffic or you can set your own and
so here's an architectural diagram you
have a server sitting in your vcn a
virtual cloud network and then you have
OCA woth sitting in between the incoming
traffic and the traffic that's supposed
to reach your server and it's going to
decide if it's good or bad based on
those rules now if you're wondering like
what are good rules for Laughs well I'd
like to filter on generally they follow
a wash top ten so you might have never
heard of a wasp their logo is a wasp but
it stands for the open web application
security project so this is a project
that is from a nonprofit organization
and what they've done is they've
detailed all the possible common attacks
that can happen and how to prevent them
and so that is the basis of the majority
of laughs out there whether it's Oracle
or any other they'll always go back to
this list but this really gives you a
clear idea as to what you need to
protect against so there you go that is
Wow
[Music]
all right so I'm going to show you how
to get started by setting up your first
Oracle cloud account so what I want you
to do is in the top right corner go to
try Oracle cloud free tier there might
be another button somewhere else but
we'll go here and then we'll hit start
for start for free and then it's going
to ask us to choose our country I am in
Canada so we will type in Canada here
and then we'll choose our email I'm
going to choose Android exam proko I'm
not sure if I've already made an account
but I guess we'll find out it's gonna
ask us between a company and a and
personal use I'm gonna stick with
personal use I'm going to say exam pro
and then we'll drop down and we get to
choose our region we could choose well
we want to do the free tier I guess it's
only free for particular tiers even
though I'm in Canada Toronto I'm going
to choose Ashburn
this is where the most available servers
are going to be and then I need to fill
out my account information so I'm just
gonna go here and fill all that out ok
okay and so now all my personal details
are filled in here you're not going to
be able to see them because I blanked
them out and we'll go ahead and we'll
verify our phone number so we now just
have to enter in the code that it has
given us so I'm just gonna check my
phone here to see if I received a code
and I have so I'm just going to go ahead
and fill that in so that's one four nine
five zero two four go ahead and verify
that code and so now we need to put in a
password so I'm just going to go ahead
and fill in a password great and so now
that I meet all the password
requirements I should go ahead here and
go to payment information and I here
it's just saying that I need to add a
credit card but I won't be charged
unless I'd like to upgrade my account so
go ahead and I'll go and add my credit
card and so here we can see my payment
information is being repeated so I'm
just going to scroll down and so now we
need to choose a payment type so I'm
just going to fill that in and now I
have that filled in I'm just going to
finish and so now we're just going to
get a confirmation here so I'm going to
hit confirm
concetto this has created my account so
I can go ahead and just log in with my
password so we'll go ahead and login
and here we are we're in my account so
this is the Oracle console and you can
see that we're under a trial for 30 days
and if we can upgrade to get access to
more things so there you go so that
that's all it takes to create an account
so one of the first things we should do
in our account is setup MFA so I'm gonna
setup MFA for my root account here so
what we'll do is we'll go to the top
right corner here go to profile
we're gonna go to user settings and we
have this button here this is enable
multi-factor authentication I'm gonna go
ahead and click that and what that's
gonna do it's going to give us this QR
code and so what you're going to need is
your gonna need to install the Oracle
mobile Authenticator or a similar
application I believe you can use
Google's Authenticator but this is a
separate application you have to install
in your phone so you have to go to the
Google Play Store or or whichever or
whichever store is on your phone and so
I'm just pulling mine up right now so I
have a sent occator and in Authenticator
I I can click a plus button it says scan
a barcode and then I'm just gonna hold
up my phone to that barcode and then
it's going to add it and so now it's had
it's now added it and it's gonna ask me
to enter in the numbers I see on my
phone so I'm gonna enter it in so I got
four two one nine zero eight and I'm
gonna hit enter and now I have
multi-factor authentication so the next
time I log in to my account I'm gonna
have to use authentic ater to enter in
those numbers so my account is secure
and that's how you set up MFA if you
have a business account it's a little
bit different and I think we do have
instructions on that on our website but
yeah for your personal account that's
all you have to do to set up MFA
[Music]
so now we're gonna look at setting up a
user account within our Oracle cloud so
if you aren't on this home screen just
always click the logo Oracle cloud here
if you are lost from the last video what
I want you to do is open the hamburger
menu go down to identity and go to users
and so what we can do is we can add more
users to our account so I'm gonna hit
create users I'm gonna make one for
Baker who is my co-founder he's also
named Andrew so that's why we call him
Baker from his last name and I need to
confirm the email I guess you can't have
a space we'll look at some advanced
options we can tag him we'll go ahead
here and create oh I'll just say
co-founder and so now I've created Baker
an account and I'll just click into him
here and he has never logged in but we
can enable MFA for him but I guess he
would have to do it himself because he
would have to add his phone we can
create and reset his password we can
edit him as a user some basic
information so that's how easy it is to
create a user so we'll just go back here
to Oracle cloud and we'll move on to the
next step so now that we have a user
let's go ahead and put them in a group
so we'll go up to the hamburger menu go
back down to identity we'll go to groups
and we'll create a group I'm going to
call this group developers I maybe will
capitalize it because our other one has
a Capitol on it doesn't matter so these
are developer group and we'll go ahead
here and create that group so now we
have created that group let's go ahead
and add bake Oh
to that developer group so I'll click in
here and then we'll just hit add user to
group and we'll choose our user so we'll
choose bake oh and I'll hit add and so
now they're added to that group and the
reason why we want to add people to
groups is so that we can apply policies
so that they have limitations on what
they can do within the platform but
we'll go back to Oracle cloud and that's
all you had to do to create
[Music]
so now let's go ahead and create a
compartment a compartment allows us to
group resources together and apply
permissions just like how groups allow
us to apply permissions to users so go
back up to the hamburger menu go down to
identity and choose compartments we
already have a compartment it's our root
compartment it's named after our account
but we want to make our own so we'll hit
create compartment let's call it
developments we'll have to give it a
description as development again it's
going to be the parent is going to be
the the root one because you can nest
these six levels down but we just need
one we'll go ahead and hit create
compartment so now we've created
ourselves a compartment and that's all
we had to do here let's go back to
Oracle cloud and we'll move on to the
next so now let's go ahead and create a
policy a policy is going to help us
limit access to resources so people
don't have access to things they
shouldn't have so what I want you to do
is go back up to the hamburger menu go
down to identity and then what we're
going to do is we're going to choose
policies now policies are interesting
because the way they are applied is that
you don't apply it you don't make a
policy and then say assign to user as
soon as you make them they're assigned
so now that we're here we need to choose
a compartment so it says view and manage
pick a compartment resource type so it
will drop this down here over here I'm
going to choose exam pro route and we're
going to go ahead and create ourselves a
new policy so I'm going to name this
policy I'm gonna just say developer
access so say developers and now we need
to write our statement and so I have a
statement here I'm just gonna write it
out so we're gonna say allow group
developers to manage all resources and
compartment development and so if I
named that all right I believe I gave
that a capital D I don't know if it's
case sensitive and we're gonna go ahead
there and create that policy and so
that's all it takes to make a policy and
really
said you know bacon would have to use
his account and he would have to see if
he had access or if he didn't I believe
that when you make new user accounts by
default they don't have any access until
they are part of a statement group so
everything is deny by default and then
you add things to allow but that's all
it takes to create a policy we're gonna
go back to Oracle cloud we're done with
this section so in order for us to
launch resources in Oracle we're going
to need ABC n and so what we're going to
do is go up to the hamburger menu make
our way over to networking and go to VCS
which stands for virtual cloud networks
and we have two options we can create a
vcn from scratch or we can start start
with a vcn wizard I'm gonna use the
wizard and so we have two options
GCM with Internet connectivity or VCM
with Internet connectivity site-to-site
VPN connect this sounds really great if
we had something a bit more complicated
like connecting onto an on-premise
network as the image shows well we want
something simple here so I'm gonna hit
start vcn wizard and that's going to
create us a bunch of resources so we'll
just name our vcn is my VCM and it's
automatically filled in us a cider block
so we have 10.00 416 and then what we
have here is the subnets so it's going
to create a public subnet and a private
subnet and as you remember from my
tutorial guide you always want your
subnets to cider block to be smaller
than your vcn because it's taking a
slice out of it now it looks confusing
because 24 is larger than 16 but the
larger the number is the smaller the
slice okay and then we'll just scroll on
down here so it says DNS resolution we
definitely want that we'll just scroll
down this all looks great and we'll go
ahead and hit next but before we do just
look it's going to create us a vcn a
public subnet a private subnet the
internet gateway an app gateway and a
service gateway so we'll go ahead and
hit next and then we'll go ahead and hit
create so we'll just wait for those to
create and so there you go they're all
have been created so we'll go view
virtual cloud network so now we have our
own vcn where we can start launching
resources within and that's going to
allow us to set up our own server so I'm
gonna go up here to or
ploud and that's what we'll do we'll
watch the server down so what we're
gonna do now is set up our own server so
what I want you to do is go to the
hamburger menu at the top we're going to
go to compute
we're gonna go to instances we're going
to create ourselves a new instance now
it gives us a randomly generated name
which is fine we can choose the OS that
we want so the Oracle has their own
version of Linux if we hit change we
have a bunch of options we can choose
from such as partner images or maybe you
have your custom images but we're just
going to stick with the Oracle version
then in order for us to launch this
we're going to actually need to upload
an SSH key but before we do that let's
just look at some of the options here so
we can change the availability domain we
can choose the size of instance they
call them shapes so if we open up change
shape we have different sizes we can
even choose the provider for the for
that you can choose bare-metal if you
want or go virtual and we're not we
might not be seeing all the options
because we are in the trial account so
if we upgrade we probably see a lot more
options but what we'll do we'll just
hide that there and what we need is we
need a private and public key and this
is a little bit hard because Oracle
doesn't give you a button just to
generate them here so what you have to
do is you have to create your own key
pair and they do have this nice page on
how to do whether you're on Windows or
if you're on on Linux or a Mac so I'm
right now I'm on a Windows machine so I
would have to use putty so you'd have to
go ahead install putty and once you've
installed it you'd search for putty gin
and again all these instructions are
here so if you are a bit lost look for
creating a key pair under the Oracle
cloud infrastructure documentation and
it's under the getting started section
okay but here I have putty and what it
wants it wants us to create an SSH to
RSA so it says find it okay
specify a type of key so in the key menu
confirm the default is RSA SSH key
and this is a bit confusing because I'm
looking at putty right here right now oh
I had a Noblin open and I'm not seeing
that so oh I guess you drop it down from
there so it says SSH - to RSA key type
for the type of key generate accept the
default key value as RSA so that's what
set is set the number of bits generated
- 204 8 so it's already set - to 400 for
8 and then click generate then we you
need to move your mouse a bit that
actually helps it generate random data
and then it's going to say so it says
move your mouse around when the key is
generated appears under the public key
for pacing oh is this age so just
talking about that leave the key the
passphrase blank we're gonna do that
save the private key click yes and then
the key pair saved in putty which will
prove proprietary you can name the key
anything you want it's BPA select all
the generated keys it appears under the
public key for pasting all SSH do not
save the public key because it does not
save the key in the OpenSSH format okay
so we'll go ahead and we will save our
private key and we'll say yes because
it's ok if we leave it blank we'll go to
desktop I'm just going to name this as
Oracle exam Pro and it's going to name
it as a dot PPK we'll hit save and so
now we just need to grab the public key
which is apparently this here so we'll
go ahead and copy that out so bit easier
on a Mac because you just run the a
single command which is I'm sure it
shows it in here for Linux and Mac and
so we'll go back over here yeah see
that's what it is for Mac you just run
that line and we'll go back over here
and we can choose or paste we're gonna I
think we just paste it in here go ahead
and hit create and hopefully that will
work and there we go so it's creating
our instance and it's starting up so now
we just have to wait for it to provision
I'm not sure how long it takes it
shouldn't take too long but we'll just
wait a little bit here
so after waiting about five minutes our
server is now running it's gone green
and so I just wanted to show you a few
things here so over here we have V and I
see so that's the virtual network
interface card that is attached to this
you can see that we want to get instance
access your connected Iranian students
using a shell we could connect so that's
why we made our private and public key
there we can see our shape configuration
that we chose if we scroll down here and
we go to boot volume you can see that it
created us a boot volume and it's
attached it looks like there's a console
connection so this might be a convenient
way to connect to the instance here you
can set up work requests so we can see
that it created an instance so it shows
us some history there but yeah that's
the instance there so yeah there we go
so now that we're done with the system's
let's go ahead and just terminate it so
we'll go to actions and we'll hit
terminate and I will permanently delete
the boot volume because we're done with
that all right so there you go now if
you wanted to make a database it's not
going to be that much different you
could do autonomous I think we get two
for free so we just go ahead here I'm
not gonna go through the whole process I
just want to quickly show you that the
way you'd set up a database is you
choose the database or the the
transaction processing or the shared
infrastructure you fill in your username
password and etc you can bring your own
license or license and create your
database that way so I just wanted to
quickly show you that but we'll make our
way back to the compute instance and we
can see that it's terminating it's going
to take a little bit of time but if we
see that we know that it's terminating
we don't have to worry about it so I
think we're all good for that so I just
click back at the home here and this
section is done
[Music]
all right so I'm going to show you how
to create your own bucket and start
using object storage so we'll go all the
way up here to the hamburger menu and
we're gonna go to object storage and
we're going to choose object storage
what we're gonna do is create ourselves
a bucket and then we'll name the bucket
whatever we want and we'll go ahead and
we can enable object versioning we don't
need to do that you'll notice that we
can use the Oracle manage keys to
encrypt it but by default it is
encrypted
we can choose standard or archive
archive is going to help us save more
money if we choose that go ahead and
create that bucket so now we can click
into that bucket and if we want to
upload objects we just have to click
upload so I'm just going to upload
something from my desktop so let's go
upload ourselves an object so we'll go
to upload object I happen to have an
image of the enterprise-d that I want to
upload so I'll just place it there I'm
gonna call that Enterprise D we can see
if there's a few other options here so
we can just change the metadata and
response header I'm just gonna leave
that all alone we'll hit upload and it
uploaded was very fast okay and so
there's our object and so on the left
hand side we do have some other options
such as metrics so we can see bucket
size and number of objects we have pre
authenticated requests so if objects are
private and we want to give people
access to it I assume we could use that
there are work requests we request as a
feature of management OS so I'm not sure
how that fits in lifecycle policies you
could create a rule probably to move it
to archive so imagine that you had a
like a lot of files and you needed to
move them into archive so that you could
hold on to them for seven years but you
wanted to move them to archive so that
you're saving money that's what you use
a lifecycle policy for those are there's
a replication policy replication would
be for backing up your data in another
region so if this region for whatever
reason suffered a disaster you would
lose your data but if you replicated it
into another region
you wouldn't have that issue there then
we have retention rules this sounds like
that you can decide whether to delete
files over time so by time-bound or
indefinite so it says objectively
modification is prevented from the
retention during period so you can say
you're not allowed to delete a file for
this period of time so imagine that you
are you have accounting files you have
to hold on for seven years you could say
hold on to these for seven years or you
could say indefinite never never delete
these files so hopefully that gives you
an idea of object storage I'm going to
go ahead here and delete this object but
that's as simple as it is so there we go
[Music]
so now let's take a look at launching a
database or at least look at the options
because Oracle is known for databases
and they have quite a few options we
have the autonomous data warehouse the
autonomous transactional processing
bare-metal VM exudate exadata data safe
which is for visualizing whether our
data is safe no SQL database and MySQL
where we have DB systems and it can do
backups we'll go to the autonomous data
warehouse and it doesn't really matter
what we choose because I think when we
choose it it allows us to choose these
two options and right now I'm under
Bakos account but let's say we want to
do transactional processing so that's an
OLTP we wanted to be shared so that it's
it's more cost effective and we want to
use the free tier always free resources
can be created in both free tier and
paid so we'll checkbox that on if you're
if you're always free e tier has no
activity seven days the database will
automatically stop so they don't want us
to really use it if we're not we can
choose our database version apparently
there's only one we have auto-scaling we
could turn that on so our database
automatically scales it's not like a
checkbox it so I don't know there our
admin credentials is going to be admin
apparently we can't change that and
we're just going to set this a password
I'm going to do testing one two three
four one two three ABC exclamation I'm
testing one two three
ABC oh it's making this really hard for
me containing at least one uppercase
lower case one number cannot use double
quotations okay so I say testing ABC all
caps one two three testing ABC one two
three and we'll just look here configure
access control rules I don't know if we
need to do any of that I guess we could
restrict based on IP to say only this
person from this IP select my only my
home address is allowed to access the
server and we're gonna use licenses
included I'm gonna look at some Advanced
Options we just have some tags we'll go
ahead and hit create autonomous database
and so it's going to start provisioning
that instance and so we're just going to
wait and I'll see you back here in a
moment so after a short wait are
autonomous database is all ready and
running and we have some options here we
can scale up and scale down which is
kind of cool we can restart it we could
create a clone we could add access
control list we could reset the password
and we can do a DB connection so let's
go ahead and click that so here it says
to download the client credentials
download the wallet so we go ahead there
and download that I'm not going to go do
that we have metrics down below if we
have backups we could see them here we
can make a manual backup whenever we
just click that put the name in and it
would create a backup crane backups can
be a little bit slow so I don't want to
do it I think right now we'd have to
upgrade to use this feature so we're not
gonna be able to do any backups let's go
to the tools and so in tools we have SQL
Developer web Oracle ml user
administrator Oracle application Express
and soda drivers I think this might give
us an interface I'm just gonna go ahead
here and click that and see what we get
and we'll just wait here a little bit
and so here we are in the SQL Developer
I wonder if it's the same if I go admin
testing abc123
and there we are and we're actually in
our database so that's a really nice
because it allows us to directly work
with our database has a data modeler
that sounds really cool um so I'm just
clicking around here so I'm not exactly
sure how this works but it's kind of
cool that we have this interface here
that's built in I haven't seen this with
any other provider I assume we just
start writing SQL so you say it select
all or show tables I can't say I really
know my Oracle I know my my squall
pretty well but we launched an Oracle
autonomous instance okay so I didn't see
any output there but it's nice to see
that we have that as an option but yeah
that is launching a database so let's go
ahead and we'll just shut down this
database
cuz we're done with it we'll just say
terminate type in the database name to
confirm termination are you sure you
want to name it here they put it there
so that you can just copy-paste it like
that that is a very nice name for a
database that's terminating so that's
all we have to do and so that's
databases so if you ever wondering like
how you can determine who is doing what
within your account there's a service
for Oracle called audit so what I want
you to do is go to your hamburger menu
we're gonna go down to security or sorry
I can't remember what it's under here
governance and we're going to go to
audit and so what audit allows us to do
it allows us to see what's been going on
within our account so if we wanted to
find out who did what that's how we can
do it you could drop it down based on
their action types the filter but based
on keywords but we can just scroll down
here and eventually you'll see my name's
you can see that I was in the database
service so I was looking at the database
service deciding whether I wanted to
start a server and then if we keep on
going down we probably would see that I
was trying to launch a server but yeah
if you're just trying to figure out who
did what in the system that is
what audit does okay that's just good to
know all right I just want to show you
another thing with billing that is
something you should probably do so if
you go to the hamburger menu here and
we're gonna go to account management and
we go to budgets we can set a budget and
a budget is really good because it's
going to help us make sure that we are
keeping track of our costs so I've
already created a budget here called the
overall budget and you can show us that
we had spent $100 and our spend so far
as four dollars and 54 cents and that's
how much of our spend period that has
occurred so far and that's how much if
forecast it's going to happen in the
future but let's go ahead and create
ourselves a new budget we can say
another budget and you can do based on
compartment or a tag it's probably gonna
ask us for a description so you choose
your component you say $100 you can
choose the threshold so actual span
versus forecast you could choose the
threshold being 50% this is gonna
determine when it actually emails you to
say hey your budget is approaching and
then you'd put your email in here and
that way you'd get an email about it so
I'll go ahead and create ourselves a
budget a budget already exists for this
component so I guess you can only make
one per compartment all right
and so I just made another one there but
I don't really need another one so I'm
going to go ahead and delete that oh
yeah you should definitely set up a
budget because you want to keep on top
of your cost so that you don't get over
billed and so there you go okay so now
what I want to do show you a little bit
about building so I actually switched
over to Bakos account because he
actually has some spend out of his free
tier you can see over here on the
right-hand side it says he's had four
dollars so far he has four days for his
his trial to end but what we'll do is
look at a hamburger menu up here we're
gonna scroll all the way down and we're
gonna go to account management and we're
going to go to cost analysis and this
will show us our free trial again so
it's the same information there it tells
us to upgrade but it's also going to
give us a breakdown of compute block
storage networking etc so here we can
see those costs in detail so I just
really wanted to show you that so you
know where you could analyze your costs
[Music]
so now we're going to look at booking
our exam and so the test center network
that is associated with Oracle is called
Pearson VUE and they do both in data
center and also proctored exams
proctored meaning from the comfort of
your own home and that's all up to you
but if we want to go start taking an
exam what we can do is go to test takers
and click on schedule an exam then we
can search the type of certification we
want so I'll type in Oracle and we'll
click here and then from there what
we'll have to do is go and create
ourselves an account we're sign-in I
don't have an account so we'll go ahead
and hit create account we're going to
have to click I agree indicate that
you've read the Terms we'll scroll all
the way down the bottom check box that I
agree so what we'll have to do is fill
in our personal information so I'm just
gonna scroll through this so you can see
so you have to put your title your first
name middle name last name suffix and
then your email so I'm going to go ahead
and do that do you know of an Oracle
testing ID now I do not know my Oracle
testing ID sorry mr. Andrew William
Charles Brown I don't have a suffix
we'll go ahead here and I'll just say
Andrew at exam pro doc Oh Andrew at exam
pro dotco
I'm sure I'll receive some marketing
messages that looks good to me there's
sports apps personal information contact
information additional information and
create an account so we'll hit next for
create an account order the next step
and what we need to do is we need to
fill in our personal contact information
so I'm gonna say I'm from home and I'm
in Canada
and I'm just going to fill in the rest
of my information here great and now
that I filled in my personal address
here I'm just going to scroll down and I
just need to fill in my phone number and
choose my corresponding language and we
can go to next and now it's gonna ask me
if I'm part of the Oracle partner
Network I am NOT if I was I would get a
discount now it's gonna ask me to make a
username I'm going to go ahead and try
to make one great and now I need to make
a password so I'm just gonna go make a
password and then it's going to just ask
me a security question great and we'll
go next and now what we can do is we can
view the exams that we want to book
and so here we have a list of exams so
we're looking for the Foundation's exam
so we could just type in foundations up
here and then we have the the course
codes here so we want to make sure that
it's the correct one you can see that
there's 20 and 20 F so I'm just going to
double check what the code is so our
code doesn't have the F I don't know why
there's one with F maybe it's like for
French
I didn't mean to click it it's just
loading now
so what we'll do is we will click the
one that doesn't have the F then it's
going to ask us where do you want to
take the test we can say in our home
office and then we can run a pre-check
you definitely want to do a pre check if
you can so what this is going to do it's
just going to check our systems we're
gonna see if we can pass right now my
webcam isn't working it's showing
something here and so this is just a
check is my audio working do have good
internet and does my webcam work I'm
just gonna go ahead next and so I've
passed of the checks so I can close this
and then go next and the next thing we
can do is we can agree to the online
policy so we have to go and click
through all of them here hit next and
then it's going to show us the price of
the exam and also what exam we're taking
and the operating systems and other
settings that matter and we'll hit next
and then here we have this option
consecutive appointments you may add one
or more exams to take on the same day
and so I'm just gonna hit next
and so now we would choose a time so I
could say you know on the on the Monday
here so we could say let's do it on
Monday and then we would need to choose
the time the only time available is 9:00
p.m. so I could also choose maybe
Wednesday where I have more available
times so here we could say 2:15
and then from here we're going to see
our options it's going to show us on my
personal information here and then all
we have to do from here is proceed to
checkout we're going to be presented
with the policies prison with policies
and then from here you just go hit
accept and you would pay with your
credit card and that's all there is to
it so the reason I don't want to go
through the whole whole end here is cuz
actually I'm not looking to book the
exam today but this is the whole process
to book with Pearson VUE and so good
luck on your exam